各位听众朋友们大家好。
欢迎收听由猫腿音许剧出品的音频节目《不开玩笑》。
想要加入听有群，可以关注公众号猫腿音许剧回复听有群。
小助手会把你拉进群聊。
欢迎大家来到《不开玩笑》我是主播实验。
我们今天聊沟通啊，然后请的都是几位老朋友来。
我们就话不多说了，我们掌声欢迎审请。
大展，阿诚还有马军。
今天这个组合非常...。
这无聊展也录呢，现在。
真下无聊展在哪录呢？
太狠了，前天就录播课一天。
我刚录完撒火过来。
就充实了，天天。
是。
又能逗大家...又能转着玩儿呢。
跟我们的屏幕前的听友解释一下啊，
这个大展现在在绿大纲。
我绿看了，昨天看了，也有点思路。
有什么？
迟到我能讲啥，放心吧。
哎呀，我跟那头脑袋都在想。
都在想我们？
在想啊，有个故事特意没跟他讲。
我说，老师不能全分享，分享一会儿到这啥还没得讲。
我们今天这个组合，阿诚那天还说呢，
几乎是我们前两年那期，
《抬杠》的翻版。
《杠》吧，开始。
你是有一副课的吗？
我没有，我只是觉得大家都...。
反正沈清也没什么事。
我很忙好吧，我也刚喂完狗过来。
我一天一天。
我们还是按照惯例，
我们先跟大家打招呼来沈清先来吧。
嗨，大家好，我是沈清。
特别开心，又来到不开玩笑。
你现在应该怎么介绍啊？
《前三言两语》的主播。
不要再给人家热度了。
他这个好像叫《三言两语》前主播。
因为这个台还在。
对，对，对。
我现在就是沈清，
《青道夫》的这个。
对，对，对，有自己的演出。
对，叫《青道夫》，
《青道夫主大秀》，
《青道夫互动秀》的演员。
是的，是的，是的。
好，来，展。
大家好，我是展安宁，谢谢大家。
大家好，我是刘仁诚。
他上来的时候，
然后沈清就问他这个求婚之后，
的一些后续的一些流程。
我说，我说你是不是快结婚了？
他说我一下跳两步，
我就问哪两步？
他说还有订婚，
还有结婚。
对于大家最近好像都是，
老见面，
跟我说新婚快乐。
是啊。
我不是说，
就感觉很奇怪，
确实差了很多步呢。
说没领证那种。
还没领证呢，
他求婚一岁。
求婚领证。
展，你了解这些流程吗？
我不知道。
我现在差得更远点。
你有对象了？
没有啊。
所以说差得更远吗？
那你知道有订婚这个流程吗？
我不知道该订婚的玩意儿。
我也不知道，是不是？
你们俩都不知道有订婚这件事。
我不知道这是一个必须的流程。
我以为是一些贵族的一些，
其实,
来你贵族给他们讲讲。
在国内，
订婚的普遍性比求婚更重。
是吗?
不是所有人都求婚的，
但现在所有人都有订婚，
因为订婚是个必须的流程。
那天阿诚隔北京，
订得婚，是吧？
我那天正好隔北京，
我没去，
求的婚，求的婚。
他那天求婚，
完了我那天找篮球馆，
我打篮球打到下半夜3点半。
特地不让他去的。
你也来订的茶。
酒店以前是石楼师给你报的，
场地位是刘仁诚给你出的。
因为当时那个，
因为是我们一个共同朋友，
一个扮演主的朋友，
帮我策划的，
然后展日从他知道的，
他大概从，
他11点就跟我说，
哎呀，早知道早知道就过去了，
早知道早就不让你知道。
从同学开始？
还能让你知道。
你们不觉得，
如果我在求婚的时候，
旁边有个宅家，
你也，也太奇怪了。
我跟你说，
我那天求婚的时候，
一个朋友都没放，
最后是有一个朋友，
他确实是，
他认识我女朋友，
所以我觉得，
有一个他认识人，
他心里会舒服一点，
也是个演员，
要气有，
演路过咱们的篮球馆。
对，气有，对。
就气有，
这个傻逼就够烦人的。
你们都想象不了，
你们的同学员都无聊，
我的那里，
就是当时我们就，
差不多到点了，
刚才就是，
我们比如说，
没半小时，
一小时，
我女朋友就要到了，
大家都很紧张，
气有一直在，
一直在问我，
是求婚紧张啊，
还是习丹决赛紧张啊。
就一直在这么骚扰我，
还能放单扣演员，
只能是你。
哎哟，那这个时候，
如果大宅在，
应该可以帮你回答一下。
他怎么回答？
你觉得，
如果,
如果让你想一想，
求婚有啥紧张的，
还能不答应啥呢？
那你俩都出我妆呢，
我感觉，
那不就走个行事吗？
他应该知道，
你那天就要求婚的，
我认为啊，
那不知道，那不知道。
那也能答应。
这太多了实践了，对啊，
不答应不及眼的。
不是，展儿，
你是奔着这个心态去的，
如果你要求婚的话，
我认为，
俩人相处，
假如说四五年了，
应该,
他就应该答应。
哎，我天，
哎，我觉得，
展儿真的是这样，
他觉得，
他三家组织决赛，
我就应该多管，
那不是，那不是，
那不是，
你彼此都信任了，
建立亲密的纪报了，
肯定能答应。
那得提前，
聊过,
我们是奔着结婚处的，
才能答应吧。
四五年，
还不结婚，
那还不是奔着结婚去的吗？
这一些进来不严重了，
我认为啊。
你,
哎，我老天爷爷，
以后跟大家谈恋爱，
得小心。
展儿怎么，
一处就要结婚，
真是。
完，离着这一步，
越来越远了，
就是这样。
那你出四五年了，
肯定,
我感觉，
不是这种吗？
啊,
一处就要结婚呢？
不是，不是，
我先处着再说吧。
我觉得，
我觉得是看，
看状况，
对呀,
很多大部分，
我觉得，
求婚,
在国内的话，
我觉得大部分都是想，
差不多了。
对,对,
我是那种，
两个人都没想好，
怎么办？
那很奇怪。
因为我常常看到，
那些美剧啊，
什么的电影，
什么的求婚，
然后对，
另外一方，
啊,
我们已经到这一步了，
美国婚，
美国人太坏了。
你还之前，
非要听到坏字太鼓掌，
就一定得听到那个字，
不是,
他是听到了咸鱼，
啊,
美国人还有结婚那天，
跑药的呢，
对,
老友记怎么来的呢？
是,
还沈清，
你有想过，
比如有一天，
突然有一个人，
求婚了这种，
就是哥，
啥时候自我介绍啊？
对啊,
你会不会有点，
不会高聪啊？
不愧是主持人，
哎,
不愧是，
不愧是当过，
有点，大家好，
我是马军，
沈清回答问题，
啊,
问题啥啊？
就是哥，
有需要的话，
我也可以答应你的求婚，
这个太合适了，
是吧?
哦,对,
那就出，
结婚了，
女人都快上小学了，
这个台上，
只能大姐爱给你求了，
我不求，
傲娇小艳，
我求，我求，
我不求，
我还是喜欢，
你们在台杠那期的样子，
你俩处了也四年了，
我记得很清楚，
他俩第一次认识，
是上级世界会，
那个时候，
路开奈统冠军的时候，
咱们,
阿诚不在，
他都是决赛选手，
对,
那个时候是，
沈清露决赛就很紧张，
大宅就一直在后边说，
你行，你行，
你肯定行，
四年了，
就是他，
当时我记得这个事，
因为你说我行的时候，
我就觉得是一个，
友好的鼓励嘛，
就是释放善意，
然后就是哥说，
就是个，
就是个往心里去了，
他说,
大宅从来没有肯定任何一个人，
因为四年前的大宅，
基本上跟我们，
这不行，
哦,
是吧？他天天说，
这也不行，
他就说，
你不行，你下去吧，
你说,
他这样吗？
你会这样吗？
我都后边，
那个背后说，
对,
当面,
当面肯定得说行啦，
哦,
谢谢你当时对我的善意，
嗯,
他是你，
在你背后说的行，
哦，真的吗？
你做第一排，
他做第二排吗？
对,
行,
他说阴阳了算，
这也太背后了，
小金,
你说你之前男朋友，
出关系男朋友，对不对？
出高中的时候，
没躲过去，
就要注意着问他，
出高中的时候，
他们也不求婚，
那时候，
那时候法律也不上，
法律那不允许，
对,
是,
从来没有想过这个事儿，
结婚这个事儿吗？
求婚这个事儿，
你有坏想过，
比如说，
有人给你求婚，
我,
我不太喜欢，
我觉得很尴尬，
我觉得，
搞那种，
就是,
众目睽睽，
交了一堆朋友，
然后给对方，
不管是男跟女，
女给男求，
就是瞒着一个人，
然后对方尴尬的，
进来说，
怎么回事儿，
然后突然，
就是你眼泪巴叉的，
就是在说，
我们经历了多少多少年，
然后你愿意嫁给我吗？
就这一刻，
我觉得，
如果我是属于
被求那个位置的话，
我都会，
我都会特别尴尬，
我就是不知所措，
我就觉得，
我,
我平时的工作，
就是在表演，
我这一刻也要表演，
我要,
我们听一下对方便有的，
他没有观众，
不是，他没有观众，
我跟他想法是一样的，
我特别怕尴尬，
我基本上没放人，
就是不叫朋友，
我完全没叫，
我当时现场，
就只有不知婚礼的，
然后当时是因为，
我觉得，
如果只有我这边，
认识的人，
感觉不太好，
所以他叫了一个妻，
就是让我女朋友，
现在有他认识的人，
那现在能问吗？
就是,
你是布置了一个现场，
所以说，
他一进那个，
现场那一瞬间，
他就知道了吧，
酒店房间不一样了呀，
就是因为，
因为进去，
你可能就能猜到了，
但是就是，
在进酒，
进门之前，
他都没有想到，
那他当时的表情，
是那种错路的，
还是开心的，
就是震惊吧，
然后就是，
对,
那你是跟他，
怎么说的，
过去那地方的，
跟他说啥，
就是我，
就是酒店的房间，
回酒店，
然后我专门，
找了一个，
是有客厅的酒店，
对,
然后在客厅不值得，
套房,
这个就是，
承诺的套房，
套房,
一般来走廊的镜头，
对对对，
最后一间，
那你求婚试词，
说了多久啊？
我没说什么试词，
就,
就一些细节，
比如说，
有下跪吗？
那肯定有，
肯定有，
我没有，
你说那些什么，
就是流着眼泪，
不然不然，
几个多少什么，
我没哭，
我笑着求的，
就应该这样，
好事儿了，
哭啥啊？
尤其是，
我说,
大家说句掏心窝子话，
我本来是，
我也嫌这个尴尬，
我不想求婚，
但是后来，
我是跟我女朋友，
聊天聊到，
偶尔聊天，
没有仔细聊，
但我,
我意识到，
她想要一个求婚，
我才去做这个事儿的，
对,
那你还挺浪漫的，
所以以我的性格，
我是懒得多这些事儿的，
是吧?
那你问一些细节了吗？
那么,
假如我是求婚的话，
是在套件儿好，
还是表演？
那,
如果你需要一场求婚证，
是不是得有个听儿啊？
是,
是电影院好啊，
还是演唱会好啊？
还是在播客现场好啊？
是录三会的时候求好，
还是不开玩笑求好？
嗯,
一个人都不能，
你放心，
我是不会，
让任何人，
在三火现场求的，
那就是害人家的，
不，离婚我欢迎啊，
去上网，
宅今年还是作为选手参赛？
累啊，累，
选手当选手参赛，
哎，你今年会有那种，
今年如果没有连续夺冠的话，
会有点，
你想啥连续夺冠？
你就没指望这事儿？
没指望啊，
肯定没指望啊，
好多人问我这问题，
你凭什么是为你能连续夺冠？
那老些冠军都没做到，
你这个人不是比较耗胜吗？
耗强,
所以,
就觉得你会不会有这样的压力？
你首先得务实啊，
得务实啊，
那世界不是为我赚的，
你要我，
他按我设计啊，
你应该十点赚，
不是，按我设计的话，
他不可能有这么多人参赛的，
还选不会选这么多人的，
那你说哪些人就不该参赛呢？
那，哎呀，那就简单，
那你要是整个不录制这些下活动，
我能给你捞一宿，
那咱们先把机器关一下，
是吧，是吧，是吧，
这都有心理透明的，
你现在没有话？
没有啊，
我觉得每个人都很优秀啊，
你可得了，你，
几年不见，
你怎么温和成这样？
我们哪有几年不见啊？
怎么一年不见，
怎么温和成这样？
我们哪有一年不见啊？
八个月不见，
怎么温和成这样？
这么细节吗？
细节吗？
你们觉得自己算是比较好沟通的人吗？
或者比较擅长沟通的人吗？
我觉得还好，
我觉得我还可以，还算好，
你算比较好沟通的是这样吗？
我感觉我也挺好，
什么叫好沟通，
其实我可以说，
其实杜安宁特别好沟通，
是吗?
他说不好沟通，
怎么会参赛呢？
这最简单的道理，
我耳根特别软，
你就是嘴硬，
但是耳根软？
嘴也还行，
我就是耳根特别软，
但是很多人，
他都是说，
看着你，
特别是不好沟通那种的，
给我留下了，
我给他们留下很多刻板印象，
杜安宁这种，
他是最吃亏一种类型，
他面恶心善，
没有,
你好好沟通一下，
面恶这件事，
就是不好沟通的，
大家都看到了吗？
没有,
我说我认真说，
因为杜安宁这种，
其实挺吃亏的，
他就是嘴上，
包括,
看起来，
干什么都是不情不愿的，
但是其实都干了，
然后还落得好，
因为他嘴上的一些东西，
表情什么，
别人觉得你刚才不高兴，
其实活都干了，
还没落得好，
其实挺吃亏的，
其实也不高兴，
但正干了，
这种坏事，
或者坏话，
没有个经纪人，
帮你们出去说吗？
什么?
理论上，不应该一人，
扮演一个好举动，
然后让经纪人去当坏人吗？
经纪人都拦着我，
财老师别说了，
对呀,
我说不行，
就得说，
我都认得，
没人拦得住我，
其实只要，
我今年我一直劝他，
别上节目，
直到他唱节目之前，
却他别上节目，
我也一直劝阿成，
上节目，
我说,
我说你来啊，
我有个伴儿啊，
要不然那陆志仁修，
我不知道跟他坐一起，
骂谁啊，那种，
只东方说服对方，
我都没来，
他太好沟通了，
是,
我吃不同意见，
我觉得面恶心善，
是有好处的，
就是,
你可以格觉一些，
你对面恶心善，
没有不同意见，
我以为在这儿呢，
不同意见，
因为我也属于，
面恶心善，
我也是看着，
不好沟通的那种人，
然后我就觉得，
我们这样的人，
他的好处就在于，
可以先天然的，
格觉一些，
很无礼的要求，
或者是很，
经历过吗？
明白，明白，明白，明白.。
就是，因为人家，
先给你假定说，
这个人肯定不好沟通，
这个人肯定，
这事儿，这事儿，这事儿，
所以他就会退让一步，
我是占了很大便宜的，
我感觉.
我敦共地那时候，
有一个，
就是进去的哥们，
他当道一半，
他就,
我原来讲过，
他就是回去服刑去了，
我林脸，
他走完之后，
我才知道，
他管所有人都借钱，
唯独不敢管我啊 贱贤。
这事
对 这就是我们的好处之一。
对对对 有道理
就是看上去不是很好沟通。
那种
他在里边见过大量像你这样面相的估计。
而且我还觉得就是。
你看 你看起来
咱们看起来不好沟通。
然后别人
最后别人沟通完之后发现。
哎 原来我们这好沟通的。
还能给人一种惊喜感。
还能让人觉得
哎 原来他不是长得那样啊？
就是比如说我
我本来觉得我都不好意思提这个事。
当我提了之后他说。
OK 或者行
我就好惊喜这种感觉。
对呀 会有吧？
你是奔着这个心态去的。
我倒不是刻意这么设计的。
人活着活着就成这样了。
沈清的意思是
我们帮了人就属于放下屠刀立地成佛。
一种话的话
我们眼前看着我们本身就是带屠刀的。
是吧？
就他们对他们气态比较低。
对对对
我明白
对
就是你跟家宁
对这个活动分
哎没打我挺好的
真的我还准备这事了。
就昨天
昨天那个晚上端稿。
我得回那个杭州的熟熟东西。
我回杭州做高铁
有一人说
咱老师能不能换桌。
您好能不能换桌
本来我不想换
本来我不想换的
但我那是B桌
他那是A桌
我说那话来不亏
我就换到前面去了。
完了换完
就听后边人去
等会等会大王还做二等桌呢？
二等桌
我自己买票我马上要等多。
哦
他后边那帮人就去去你。
哎那杭安宁吗那事。
那脱油冠军什么的。
然后那人说
那不对也杭安宁不换桌啊？
原话是啪
在这呢？
完了等到
你塌房了
人设塌了就是
好像等到过了家庆之后。
旁边那俩人就走了。
完了他那后边那人就坐旁边了。
我问是不是宅老师。
完了他说
我就说是完了合不合影。
我说合影
完了他还是阿里的。
跟我讲了很多阿里的八卦。
他们怎么部门斗争啊？
叮叮那怎么回事
他给我讲了
我说给我讲了一道啊？
我觉得宅确实是这样。
就是有时候你觉得。
你跟他聊件事
他如果答应你
你都觉得
很开心
就是他回复你一个行。
你都觉得很开心
而且大宅回复行
跟别人不太一样
别人回复行
别人回复你就回复一个行。
大宅回复一个大协的行。
什么意思
没有 就是二十年前的言误。
那种行特别大
左右两边
就是他是
赤处
两个偏旁行的两个偏旁。
拆开来
你就怎么打了就打赤处。
赤处啊？
宅家宁跟你上大行。
太行了
对
你收到过宅的行吗？
好像没有收到过一个单字吧？
有 两字啊？
你看他没赤处
赤处
我回答对都是幼寸。
显着真诚
哦 是吗？
真诚
他有这狗屎计诚
我拒绝过你吗？
我也没跟你提出过什么诉求。
就是
你答应什么路博客干啥。
就是我一般都都来。
有空我就来
对
是吧？
我下次
我下次找你借钱试试。
你会答应吗？
看多钱呗
五十万
那起来没有
没有
那五千呢？
五千
赤处
怎么就落上了呢？
五千行
我看他底线是多少。
你一步一步来
方便我诗诗
这个叫上线
这上线
赤处
你还回别的这种吗？
就是幼寸
还有别的吗？
左右
我还回人家那个特别正能量的表情报。
就是有个懒洋洋那个。
我为什么发表情报。
我给你讲这事
我突然想起来的
就是我说啥
人家就以为我阴阳他。
我也有这个会扰你。
不是就这个事
对
我前两天跟一个就是上海的朋友。
他问我到没到
我说进屋了进屋了。
他说哎呀？
那行
帕斯基跟你合影
我就回他一句幽默。
他给我回
你可真气人的
我就是
我就
他说帕斯基跟你合影。
我不是开玩笑吗？
我说你幽默
他就说你可真气人的。
我就问他
我说真心法问
我得怎么回才能不气人。
他说妈的问到我了。
咱就正常回客户
你这就得回表情报。
喜洋洋的表情报
对
我特别理解
我也身受困扰
你一定很简单
在你看来很简单打字。
他就
不知道为什么？
阿诚算是比较擅长用这种表情报。
或者什么的
对
我有时候跟人俩听我不说话。
我都不打字
我一直发表情报
我最近喜欢发诸书侠。
而且我最近发现
其实微信有搜索表情报的功夫。
对对对
然后对
你最近才发现
我最近才发现
他上线两年多了
对
我到现在都没发现。
我的功能就是这样子。
这微信可以自己搜一个表情报。
你可以搜一个
关键词
比如说
诸愤怒
你就可以发
你就可以搜一个愤怒的诸。
我特别会用这些
我反正我自己
是很喜欢用表情报的。
因为我不太会跟人正常聊天。
我不太正经聊天
这就是科技带给人类的病别。
这一段
你这还是个微信
你抖音都都
就互相甩视频都
对对对
我发现就是
大家现在沟通
这反而是
语言文字
放在很后面
变成蚂蚁了人都
就相互碰一下
就想知道对方想什么？
好哲学啊？
这个就哲学了
你是余祥语
看多了吧？
你是抖音刷少的
你就是
就俩人互相甩
对
我光听他们说
因为我很少玩抖音。
我刚听他们说
就是互相那个
在抖音就甩视频
什么对的
我们现在
这很常态的一种
我们是每天
互相给对方发视频。
发大概多少亮
就一天大概也不多。
四五十条吧？
对
那是算多的
十六个一般的
你的这个沟通对象一般是。
其实能跟你讲
那种习惯的人不多。
那就是都得是比较。
特别合得来的那种。
在这种互联网中
幽默的审美上
对
反正我
就是我
反正我最近跟哈曹。
应该已经互相发了一百多条视频。
没说过话了
俩人没说过话
但是火花是六十多火花。
那你拿每一条
你都会打开看吗？
不看
不
而且有的就是
根据相关法律
该视频不可见了
真是的
那就是看完了
看完了
那那那
搞笑的视频尺度
也很大的
朋友们
很大的
我们是只给对方发。
但不看对方发的
他有时候躲一会
给你挑到主页了
因为发了多了
对
他会给你推荐
对对对
他给你推荐那张视频。
对对
他推荐的
有时候你看那张视频。
你各样发给他
发不了
是他发给你的
对对对
反正这样会这种事。
只按你办公室发
跟那个私语发
跟那个谁嘻哈也发。
还有谁
产灵界也发
产灵界发
雷哥在你这就
会是雷哥
因为我感觉主要是。
感觉雷哥是不是跟。
像差不多
应该不太会玩机器。
他现在
对我
尽力都在抚养孩子上。
是是是
我跟雷哥天天互相发。
是吗？
发什么？
冬天男人不掉发秘诀。
哈哈哈哈
那应该发
石老师在护发这个赛道。
我觉得有趣
对
很有心思福利
今儿呢？
你有什么？
我是
我好沟通到
几乎到窝囊的地步了。
这个就是
我是一个
就是一个事
我只要想明白了
这个事就过去了
前两天在沈阳
我去丹东演出
然后从沈阳下飞机。
然后在坐火车
转车去沈阳火车站。
我在火车上
两
一号线还是二号线。
互相换车
在一个广场站
换车的时候
上来一个大哥
我下去他上来
他上来就给了我一手机。
故意的
很明显是故意的
然后就往我行口
就帮就给我来一下。
然后就直接把我就弄蒙了。
他想跟你说句
掏心我自己话
我说这是咋了
然后我就拎着箱子下车。
晚上我就回头瞅着他一眼。
然后他上车我下车。
他就给我来一酒
就踹我屁股上了
然后车门就关上了。
然后这事就结束了。
我也没办法再追上去。
就跟他争论这个事。
然后我就特别窝囊。
我就拎着箱子继续赶路。
我再去丹东的高铁上。
我想明白这个事
我好像那天
我穿了一件山东泰山队的球衣。
他有可能是辽宁铁人队的球迷。
因为我们第一轮
我们赢了辽宁队
他可能在自己的城市。
看到一个泰山球迷。
然后他就窝火
他就给我来一下
明白
这就是尼克斯对马斯球迷干的。
然后呢？
这个事我想明白了之后呢？
Fuck Ma Jun。
这个事在我这就结束了。
我就挨了一下
还挨了一脚
我就想明白了这事。
找自洽
对
他就结束了
所以我应该是最好沟通的。
比如说
要有活先订人
你可以先订我
然后当天下午告诉我。
就是又找了个人
就没你
我也能接受
但是现在这种机会。
就越来越少了
因为找的也比较少了。
我可能是这种人
就相对的
别闹了
再闹眼泪出来
没有
无所谓
对
一个人
对我们这种老年人。
干什么都很心酸
对对对
你要盖回去
其实不心酸
对
就无所谓
我觉得也正常
你奥古呢？
三龙人你奥古
我其实挺想问大家。
就是比如说
平时沟通的这个过程中。
大家有没有特别吃的那一套。
或者特别不吃的那一套。
太好了
我比较
我比较反面种
聊到现在终于进大岗了。
第一个问题
你们三火是什么时候进大岗。
你跟我说
三火现在都聊一半了。
就每期可以聊百分之五十大岗。
差不多
完了就问观众
什么那种情爱小三问题都。
现在观众都不需要。
都是吗？
需要一个空间
来表达这些事吗？
你们也这样了吗？
不是
你拦不住
你不是你
我们谁这样
是这个世界王那个方向在变。
你拦你拦不住
你只能正向的引导他。
怎么引导呢？
我就说那我是两年不见。
喜剧播客
现在全都变锁多马了。
就现在就是
对啊？
大家怎么引导呢？
我挺好奇
什么引导
怎么正向的引导
就是如果有人聊了一个。
小三的话题
小三
引导啥
挺着
不是你要不喜欢
这不是流量
你不剪出去不就得了吗？
你跟他都全剪没啊？
我没说不喜欢的
他自己这儿还在这儿批判。
我没批判的
说现在世界就这样那样了。
对世界就这样了
但我接受啊？
是
你就拉一推他避就完了。
他的意思是世界变成。
他喜欢的样子了
但我刚才还讲的
就我会越来越感慨。
他那个线上那个脱口秀。
和现象可能就越来。
区别越来越大了
对吧？
你看你线上那些内容和那现象。
那完全已经完全不一样了。
就现象那个播客
录的90%的内容。
你在那个脱口秀总益里。
可能完全看不到了。
是
我感觉以后可能越来越难了。
我就害怕有一天
那个假如说观众是节目。
认识你一到现象
你怎么这样
那就那就那就糟糕了。
是不是
你现在还没到
看来那天避的就是被粉丝避掉的。
不知道
这是个地狱笑话
对
不知道不知道
就是大家有没有特别吃火。
特别不吃那一套
你刚才说你喜欢
我们还是按打钢来。
没有 我比较烦那种什么时候。
都打电话的
打电话沟通
我之前有一次
一个小龙书上一个号。
他确实是看到那个主页。
你能知道他是
某个艺人的
经纪人
代理
对
然后就跟我各发私信说。
什么廖老师有什么？
有方便电话沟通吗？
也什么事都没说
就是方便电话沟通。
然后我一想看人家也确实是什么？
艺人的经纪人
我说你尊重一点
我说那一小龙书可以打电话吗？
我就接了
小龙书可以打电话。
很少
应该是那批批的我的功能。
是
就语音这种
就是语音对话嘛？
对
我就接了
就发现是特别特别小的一个事。
类似于什么？
大家比方叫什么上海拼盘。
你能不能来一趟这种。
而且我根本就不会去那种。
我倒觉得这种事
你就我一开始跟我说了。
我就直接回答你不去就行了。
你就非要说能电话沟通吗？
我觉得这个特别浪费我时间。
我挺生气的
展你是希望怎么样的沟通。
比如文字
语音
电话
当面
我希望人个人之间。
就少沟通
除了商务下单就不要沟通。
你们我感觉现在人认识的人。
有点太多了
是是是太多了
你一天我靠这一
全是消息我的妈
你要再加两个群
哎呀我还加两个那个拼好饭。
他们抢单去
哎呀太累了
哎现在大王这么下沉吗？
你你你装啥呢你
我知道我知道你真进了。
那你何必呢？
我真进了呀？
为啥呢徒啥呢？
找素材你对呀对呀？
我我现在给自己调求回航楼。
回我租的房子里必做地铁。
必做地打车不行
那就是忘本人的就是。
真必做地铁
你看上海是第一百货商店。
每团拼好饭群我都隔离呢？
天天你能抢事
群里能有啥
那个能比你正常跟每段。
每团买更还能便宜三五块的。
真的假的
这留发链击啊我给你拉进来。
你把大家都拉进去。
本期节目有美团拼好饭。
是有情但住不住
真的你有感觉沟通很累吗？
有的时候我答应人家。
但是我真忘了
就比如说谁用哪就是几周年。
俱乐部几周年了
能不能录录个视频是什么的。
完了是这个什么那个开专场了。
能不能让让写一个那个什么推荐语。
推荐语我不理解推荐语有什么用。
有用相当有用
比如说一个完全没有名的演员。
他就可以宅嘉宁推荐演出。
叉叉叉叉
然后很多人搜了宅嘉宁。
就误会买那张票
对很多人会以为是宅嘉宁的演出。
然后就买错票
然后就在那骂这有啥用啊？
这不诈骗吗？
他也没诈骗因为他写的就是推荐。
那是副作用啊那是。
有点用
但是大部分时候没有用。
大家看清楚就没有用。
对小部分时候看错了那也不太好。
你这个就像那个卖书邀风吗？
什么罗永浩梁文道推荐的那个。
人家讲一个特别好笑的时候。
这个真事就是这个话题的。
有个上一个演员叫顾仁。
知道知道知道
韩晋的老师
对对对也是我一直认识一个演员。
他就找我给他写专场推荐嘛？
我给他写了
然后他还找博洋写了。
所以他那个大麦上写就是。
刘仁成张博洋推荐。
故人脱口秀
以为挂了
然后有一次
有今年
今年清明节
不用讲了知道哪种了。
清明节
他在上海办了一个专场。
我就念我刷小红丝我就刷了一个差评。
也不是差评啊？
那个女生就在抱怨自己。
没看清楚说
那我真是看错了
我以为今天是刘仁成跟张博洋。
两个人在清明节办的环节故人的脱口秀。
他觉得在清明节办这么一场演出也合理。
本来想聊那个沟通。
大家吃不吃哪一套。
吃不吃哪一套
那我来我说一个正经的。
我就吃跟我一样
实称的沟通
你想要的就说
我能给我能换得相应的利益。
我咱俩就成
直接点那种
我不吃那种
就是明明是
你想让我帮你办一个事。
但你说的好像是
我再给你一个机会。
对对对
你懂我说的那个感觉对不对。
就是那种
不平等的沟通
或者是错位的沟通。
我就很讨厌
然后我特别
我特别不是那种社会规讯的体面人。
就是你看
比如说很多人这么沟通。
对方就会给个台阶就接了。
就说哎呀那行
谢谢我们一起什么长期合作。
我就会直接戳
我说谁修谁啊？
这这这之类的这种。
就是我就一定要给他戳。
但其实这也不是很好。
一个问号先发过去。
也不至于发问号吧？
反正就是会稍微
那个小小的小阴阳一下。
那沈清那这种
这种真诚的尺度
他得有多高呢？
比如说不说脏话就行。
不是比如说沈清老师。
我们非常喜欢你的清楚。
但是我们是一个新成立的俱乐部。
我们目前没什么钱。
我知道你现在演出。
比如说十万块钱一场。
俱乐例子
哎呀我怎么我许愿。
接接接接
那那我们现在因为没什么钱。
八千一场行不行
我还还喜欢你
他就说不行了就完了。
不行呗那就
我我我会说哦
那感谢你的信任
但是如果
现在这个时间的话。
我可能不太合适
如果我有空于的时间。
我可以考虑一下之类的。
那那这个真诚能打多少折。
你这就不真诚
我真诚啊？
你就不真诚
什么是没时间这不钱的事吗？
是钱的事
那你看比如说我十万一场演出。
我这个这个月我排满了。
排了二十八炒
我还有两天空于时间。
我们的八千
传出去沈清一个月一二百八十万。
传
接接接接
你混的啥
一个月挣人一天的钱你这事。
没有
但这个事
我照这个结完例子。
我再考虑一下应该补解。
因为十万跟八千
因为八万
因为八千现在对于我来说。
就是还是挺诱惑的。
哈哈哈哈
换成真实情况吧？
一千跟八十
哈哈哈哈哈哈
那我会说
你找刘仁诚吧？
哈哈哈哈
刘仁诚愿意接
但我我也
我就是我跟沈清差不多。
我选那种说特别清楚的。
对对对
比如说有个什么活。
几月几号
关于什么的
多少钱要你干什么？
全部给我写出来
然后就问我意愿
我喜欢这种这种的要求。
是
不需要任何沟通技巧。
全部写出来就行
我觉得让我自己考虑。
你有时间去就去
不去就不去
我还发现我们这行。
有一个就是我比较介意的点。
就是很多人
聊合作
不谈钱
是
他不提钱
这个就很可怕
是应该放前面说的东西。
就这个活多少钱
你看你有没有意愿。
是
而不是我这有个活。
你有时间嘛？
然后对方有时间
然后也不提钱
不是
因为因为咱们这行呢？
没有那么透明
你比如说你去买辆车。
或者你去买个房子。
至少有一个市场价在那。
这一行没有
很多是假方问
以方说你多少钱
这一个活你要多少钱。
然后以方会问
假方你有多少预算。
然后这边也不说
那边也不说
我
原来应该
我应该不吹牛
是吃这亏最高的人。
讲讲
我从来我从来不问钱。
我
因为我相信所有的同行。
你觉得应该有个市场价。
差不多
我认为对
我认为我就是获得什么成绩了。
你超过就应该
应该是这个价格
后来我发现
不是
我不我不跟大家一吹牛。
我去既然决赛那年。
我比一轮有利的人都便宜。
这事了
因为你之前没有人。
没给我谈
当我后来
你是八十那个呀？
差不多
我就说来帮个忙什么的。
我感觉挺好的
而且确实比你当现代人。
已经涨价了
对对对
但当我知道真相之后。
我靠我巨愤怒
你发现你第一
然后你你以外
人家那个第十的可能是个八万。
对对对
就差这么多
他他他你也让你证据。
对
你得了冠军之后啊？
不是
就是第一年第一年之后。
当现在也也就剧少剧少剧少的。
没他我知道那个是。
咱咱就太不问了
这有时候就太那个了。
你所以你这有个经纪人给你干这个事啊？
现在有了
不是那你当时演的。
不也是大剧场面
一些靠谱的俱乐部。
对对对
哎呦
我很震惊
就因为他们这还是定价。
就没有一个
还是定价的一个毛。
所以就只能
那一年是特殊情况。
就只有习丹一那一年是那个情况。
因为
往年呢？
以前效果在的时候呢？
效果统一定价
对对对
不存在这个问题
什么成绩
对影差不多少价
所有的
线上演员都是效果演员。
所有
所有线上演员都是效果效果。
效果有自己的定价标准。
他分党
sabc什么的
我还实在
我一拼盘一拼盘讲三十分钟。
对哦
你这种最烦人你知道吗？
都让你卷起来了
拼盘一个人规定就十五分钟。
你就想什么就你吵。
不是就你时间充足。
就你段子多
给别人多大压力啊？
别人讲十五分钟整个头来似的。
死去吧你
你想十八二十分钟都合理。
是真烦人
刚才你还说同情我了。
我希望两位好好沟通。
逼的太快了
刚才还聊求婚啊？
结了后可不就这样了。
我对呀？
原来你不是爱看这玩笑的人呢？
沈清天天在家里说。
财家庭这回也出去接了28个。
我就待会这点下来呢？
这肯定不对是吧？
以后你就给大宅当经纪人。
对对
就是大宅你定一个家。
然后多出来的部分。
全都是经纪人的
这事就好了
那我也不那么黑
但是我是那种
肯定把钱放在前面聊的人。
这个其实是好的沟通方式。
对
那年只有两三个月吧？
大家都很模糊
后来大家演员也学聪明。
还是互相聊了
对 互相问
以前就大家也不问。
以前大家总觉得
以前都不太沟通
但是后来就发现
这事还得沟通
正常的职场的修持说。
对对对
职场还说是不是
员工兵该交流工资。
对
后来发现我们这不是职场。
你如果你那么玩的话。
容易去大亏
是
我那两月就是越问越来气。
越问越来气
那你找那个主办方说了这个情况吗？
但你事后说那些
你很计较
对
为什么不能显得计较呢？
我真说了
但他那个情况太
他那个情况
咱们这太过分了
好多就一锤的买卖。
他那太过分了
你知道我是怎么说的吗？
我说你好
你这场给我这些钱。
我不要
我免费眼
我就你要
因为你这些钱
我知道别人多钱了之后。
我在拿这些钱
我感觉我
就其实不是钱的问题。
我感觉就是这个
不如人格了
这个面子的问题
我说那我就给你免费眼。
但是我要发朋友圈。
我免费给你眼
后来他们就给我一顿道歉。
那给钱给你补了吗？
我没补
我不解释我不演
我就我就要免费眼。
要不你就给我取消。
后来就取消道歉取消。
我认为我一点没错。
不是
你是没错
但你啥也没落着我。
对对对
你也没
也没威权
因为
因为我
就在这嘴嗨
对
因为我坚信
我一个面恶心善的。
因为我坚信这个路还长。
就未来
对对对
你要你一定得是
真诚实的这个钱
未来
对对对
未来能挣更大的钱。
对
那所以
首先小人后军子其实是好事。
你把钱
都说清楚是好事
我们很多听友其实还很那个。
一直在关注
就是你当年海南那个钱要回来。
没有根本就没有
后来就没有下巴了。
没有下巴的那些那批人都没下巴的。
那个人那个人跑了都跑了。
再不然中国都不知道了。
那你新西兰那个钱要回来了吗？
新西兰真巧
他没钱我钱
我正是赶上就第一批钱。
那个他给我多少钱。
因为那个我演的也便宜。
我是按照国内的价格。
演的国外的价格
我是最便宜的那批人。
所以他没钱我钱
实际国内外是两个价格。
不是
主要是
主要是宅也是上完节目之后去演。
对对对
也带票什么的
所以大伯也非常非常便宜。
所以他给你
那其他人的钱他给了吗？
没给
哎呦我天
所以就办不下去了。
这事就很影响海南。
所有举动部
海南现在有些举动部。
出来约演员都要先给钱。
人家主动提
就是这好
这这几号几号
你有没有时间
我说有
他说你是什么价格。
他说那我钱先给你。
你一定得来
这请务必相信我们。
是正经俱乐部
我我最怕就是说
就是我判断这个沟通。
就是看他对我的这个称呼。
就如果他叫
比如说十老师
我觉得这应该是个比较正常的沟通。
嗯
我最怕就是啊？
你说没有继续听完问。
十老师您说
那不然人家会叫你什么？
我就很好奇
他不然是什么？
他叫我兄弟
哦
我感觉你要埋在东北人了。
可以
你这有点过分敏感。
说说说
就是他就说兄弟
我们最近有个什么什么项目。
什么什么我给你聊一聊。
哦
这个一般就很难贪欠。
他也不会主动贪欠。
就是他只要叫我十老师。
咱们有个项目
基本上都能谈
那你可以给他回一个。
亲兄弟名算账
哦我
我还让沈庆当我经纪人吗？
嗯
有四个字一说出来。
就说明他就是不想掏钱。
嗯
就是战略合作
哦
还有另外四个字
资源置换
对
一般就一出来就不想给钱。
就这种不同
对
那我感觉资源置换有的时候挺好。
啊是吗？
有的资源是有意义的吗？
这个词发明出来的时候。
肯定是有意义的
后面被烂用了吗？
对对对
但是你们
你们还有别的
比较反感一些沟通方式。
比如获西尼尼什么之类的。
我讨厌获西尼
我特别讨厌聊正事的时候。
有第三方在这获西尼。
嗯
这类似
就比如我们在正经讨论一个事。
说比如说哎这个
我的想法是什么？
你的想法是什么？
两个人在很认真聊。
然后对方可能觉得。
他单方面觉得我们有一些火药味啊？
之类的
但其实我们沟通双方我们。
就是很正常的聊天。
就是很正常的在说。
这个事该怎么处理。
第三方突然来一个。
哎呀不要说了不要说。
大家都不容易
我想给你一曲
有你啥事了
我觉得很
就是很很讨厌这种。
获西尼的
对
我觉得我
我主要是
我这两年
经过前两年上节目。
忙有很多种很奇怪的东西。
比如说一些
一些老家那边的
包括一些门窗行业的。
就是
我最害怕那种什么？
说我们这个活动
不是商业活动
哦
那就是一分钱都不准备给。
是慈善活动
他就说这是一个什么？
哎呀这个不挣钱
这是大家什么热闹。
是个论坛是个峰会。
什么什么什么？
我操
你都不知道我们这个。
门窗行业
就门窗行业都有很多这种活动。
我有一次就是一个人门窗论坛。
门窗博览会
对对高峰论坛
有一次人看
本来加我微信我都把怎么来的。
我就不说是哪个省的。
是某某省
某某省门窗协会秘书长。
门窗秘书长
然后是什么有
什么年底有400多人的行业盛会。
你举办手介
门窗行业脱口秀大会。
因为您是门窗行业。
脱口秀影响力第一人。
诚志邀请你出席活动。
问题是谁是第二人。
这有第二个你三个人吗？
你哥要你哥
唯一人唯一人
我最后我一个人嘛？
唯一人
然后给我发了一个。
goat
门窗goat
然后给我发了嘛？
我一开始没回来
给我发了个什么邀请函。
说帮我让我帮忙拍视频。
我就说不好意思
我这也没看到
我说如果是商业合作。
可以加我经纪人的微信什么什么的。
他说
不属于纯粹的商业合作。
你称呼你咋没读呢？
刘总
刘总好
因为我们是行业协会。
这次活动也是门窗人的盛会。
您的差率和
差率非我们来安排。
但不属于纯粹的商业合作。
我就知道肯定是不想给钱了。
这是纯粹的白条
然后我就说
你并得
有时候我
就算你说你不是纯粹。
但你可能自己挣钱什么的。
我存在不了
因为我有经济公司的话。
就算我不挣钱
这也是违约的
这是一个商业活动。
我就把我经济文件推过去。
然后他就说行了
我跟他聊一下
那你能不能先拍视频呢？
哎呦我天啊？
疯了吧？
我觉得就是
你都不认识他
从来没见过
我回去一对这种人。
但是又很害怕
托我就是好像也不稳定。
也不敢想回门窗
也不敢删
感觉寄了一些人脉是有用的。
我放心等你托我就讲不了。
你就不是门窗第一人了。
这很现实的
肯定不是以后是
我想这些人脉是
主要是以后啊？
方便去他们那里打工主要是。
上个班是啥
是秘书啊秘书
好我我这种事经历的特别多。
接受是是
还有那种比如说
一股脑的
为你好的这种沟通方式。
大家有经历过吗？
这个好像一般在家人里面会比较多。
什么为你好
让你就逼着你敢呀？
对那三伙那不全是那死性吗？
那我说
什么？
怎样你我告诉你
那欧击系列再录你们就废了。
就
全是死性啊？
所以你们不录了吗？
谁说的不录了
欧击用完了什么不录。
什么？
妈呀那么陷我今天。
哈哈哈哈
哎你又没有做过一个流量特段。
在哪个欧击上完节目之后。
这样的私信的数量达到了颠峰。
其实跟哪个没关系。
他就是不喜欢不热闹的这个。
这个系列都不行
他他就喜欢那种
就是触触感
就热闹闹闹了
欧击用完了
欧击那开启新系列吧？
央似大
啥意思
rookie啊？
年轻的新星
专门找那种谁都不认识的单号演员。
那聊啥呀？
找观众不就完了吗？
他们又不是没干过。
那就是打着为你好。
这也长片大论的私信。
什么就是这种人啊？
就为你好这种我就废了。
这路你就废了
你们采纳吗？
我回头我是旧路
不挺旧路
略略略
哎如果是你的真的粉丝的话。
搞不好这条
他打印下来就挂墙上了。
不知道
翟佳琳回我了
还给我卖猛呢？
略略略
我觉得就是
翟佳琳实体给我回一个。
略略略我真的
我什么都能接受了。
他其实经常回
略略略吗？
不知道
不是 我的意思说他当面。
你给我说一
略略略
得了吧？
你
还没接近我呢？
你怎么办啊？
哎
吃醋
我搜了一下
那个大家给我发过最多的。
就是吃醋
嗯有求必硬
有求必吃醋
很少给我发
好人
略略略这种东西
都宣传宣传
是
现在对
对我这个形象很重要啊？
哎
你最近有
特别做发型吗？
没有啊？
没有吗？
我觉得你现在发型比。
去年好像
更
啥
装啥
是一三五块钱
一次一直这么减的。
没有
他比以前长一点
他以前对
就是更
我想想那个形容词。
应该叫什么？
干啥吗？
婉约
是吧？
佳佳琳变理情绪后来。
你
你你没有感觉吗？
我觉得我我
确实有段没见差了。
我觉得他这次这个发型。
好像
柔和了一点
是不是
是不是这感觉
你你是不是
哪就没有独立思考能力。
我一直这样
不是
你之前不是
啥
一直160
没有即时没大变化。
就只不过他有的时间更短。
然后
对
他现在稍微长了一点。
他以前有时候也是这样。
对啊？
一直这样
我感觉就是现在婉约了一点。
好像柔和了一点
您说啥是啥吧？
石老师
石老师别说了
你再说一点像骚扰了。
说什么？
我们想聊一些特殊的沟通。
就比如搭扇或套近虎这种。
我觉得我们杨宠物。
其实是一个非常好的勾件。
搭扇场景的这么一个方式。
但是我就没有享受到。
任何这方面的红利。
是狗不行还是
我不行
对 因为你说按理来说。
狗狗已经很努力了。
然后六狗的时候
哦 你现在有两只了。
一直
两个小狗哎
我的妈呀？
我回去好好练普通话。
石老师对不起
就是你的爱马士和。
对方那个狗狗
因为我有一只小狗。
没有
刚刚不是听错他理解错了。
我去六狗
按理说我们应该是一个。
一正常说话就行
我们应该是一个
很好认识对吧？
跟帅哥要
宾主近欢
对 大家就是可以很快就建立联系。
加微信
然后成为朋友的这么一个场景。
但我不知道我是不是。
性缩力太满了
怎么着
别这不说别这么说。
我从来没有因为六狗。
认识过一个帅哥
但认识过女性朋友。
然后现在成为很好的朋友。
女性朋友是有的
那也很好
完全没有
是没有帅哥
还是没有认识帅哥。
两者都少
但还是有帅哥的
也有帅哥在那六狗。
对
看见过一些
但是没能产生联系。
是不是因为爱马士。
没跟人家狗玩
爱马士这样的
这个爱马士
哎呀？
我也是
这个也是
我心里的一根刺
因为爱马士
他非常好
他非常亲人
他有一个圈圈
他太爱叫了
然后他这个叫
会给一些第一次见面的人。
他不知道这是要攻击。
人家会很那个
然后我每次都会说。
就解释一下
我说不好意思
我叫狗太爱叫
他肯定不攻击
然后看对方信不信我。
他说信我
就会放他的狗狗过来闻一闻。
他要不信我
可能就直接就拉走了。
对
因为一般的狗主人。
他会担心狗
因为一般狗爱叫
可能就爱发生冲突。
所以他确实可能会不太信。
但我们家爱马士
完全他一点都不攻击。
他就是纯犯贱
你知道吗？
结果是爱叫
但是叫就叫
嘴贱
越说越像我了
但他不攻击
他就是叫
我那个叫
我也是找训权师
然后找Deep SIG。
都聊过他
Deep SIG怎么聊呢？
你说我的狗太叫了。
对
而且我们家的狗
他是怎么着
他就是
尤其对拼中狗
叫的最欢
他见狗狗叫
吐狗不叫
结夫计评
这个阶级感比较明显。
对 他见小狗狗
就是立刻能玩到一块去。
然后别人去闻
因为狗狗社交不是闻小屁股吗？
对
他也不反感
但是凭中狗过来闻。
他就
就这种
现在就来又像佳宁了。
对上等人比较过敏。
向上冒犯
说向上冒犯
对
我们家门口之前不是那个狗公园。
然后有一次哈曹来上海。
我好像你也提过
就我说哈曹来上海。
我说那带你赶上最上海的地方。
他吃点什么西餐什么的。
去当上去狗公园
我真的狗公园
我在那里坐了一两年。
从来没有人找我聊过天。
搭山什么的
哈曹往那一坐
就有一个喝醉的法国人过来了。
男的
为什么？
不知道
然后就转着哈曹聊两个小时。
用中文
用英文
那他是哈曹说的长傻话。
他没听出来可能
但那个人是法国人。
他英文也不好
这两个人英文都不好。
然后就是在那里聊。
这个故事跟狗有什么关系呢？
在狗公园
而且真的有共同语言的话。
语言不是
这个是谁带了狗
还是说这个话题跟狗有什么关系。
没有 就是说我说狗公园很好社交。
大家去哪可能
对 因为我是我
我自己性格也比较没。
然后我也不好意思说话。
我觉得如果我有小狗。
我想认识人
我现在真的很好
比如说白天
所谓的狗主人往那一坐。
然后因为那个狗公园可以放绳。
手都可以跑
你往那一坐 让狗狗在那玩。
然后你们就有一句没句聊天。
其实真的挺好的
而且也有共同话题。
对 就是你家狗
又叫我家狗头上了什么的。
这是很正常的话题。
社交上
假如你有什么主动跟人搭扇狗。
或者说这种套近乎的。
从来没有
你怎么交新朋友
工作
只能通过工作认识人了吧？
我感觉是这样
我要是不讲透秀
现在估计就是
你在你当前
当年那个环保公司。
那个宝哥
你那个主管
你这个公司
你现在还留下多少个朋友。
你就说
零
因为同事你就是离开了之后。
就是取农人杀了
真真真
就拉倒了
人都有差粮
对
贾安琪
你要是不讲透秀
你微信能超过两百个人吗？
不超过
我真的
我说我这24年
到现在家的人
应该超过我前30年。
所有的
就是加过所有人
我这两年就智利肥月。
我就简直就是
就是认识人
那结构的完全不一样。
我现在跟很多人出于吃饭。
你都
你就是感觉
不靠我怎么来这的。
你问
他们一聊都是
我原来是哪个
舞蹈学校的
我是戏剧学校的
我是哪个上戏
做那的
我说我
就学环保
我冬宫地什么的
然后到这个环境下。
他们就交点
全在你身上了
因为他们的什么？
什么学戏剧
表演的一些故事
他都听烂了
对
他就会看
听你讲讲
你当年什么？
逃分什么的
完了你就
你就把当年怎么逃分。
怎么讲
讲脱修这个故事
又给人讲了一遍
你这一讲
我们大概知道
你接下来要参加什么节目了。
什么节目
跟一些跟舞蹈的表演的。
春晚队
还有戏剧
这一定是大成综合性的节目。
不一定
你们有那种
不会不会打扇
不会打扇
对
但你们会碰见那种。
比如说刚才我们说。
狗狗我觉得是一个。
就是其他
比如说潘老乡
或者潘
就像
就潘关系这种
我好像在
在上海
我因为我没那个性都不敢。
我们唯一一次主动潘老乡。
就是因为我
去年发现一家江西小炒。
我听的口音特别像我们家那块了。
而且我还是吃了六七次之后。
才跟他聊了一下
我说你是不是那的人。
再去简单说两句
也没有到认识的程度。
那我想起来
我经常跟网约社司机聊天。
真的
我认为他们特别不容易。
我基本上聊所有网约社司机。
他们现在一天工作的小时。
如果你想挣钱
12个月
给14个
就14个拉底
完了
中间就是
基本上
他只有在车充电的时候。
他休息
我为什么想跟他们聊天呢？
我就问他们
每次我都问一个问题。
那吐血演员老说你们臭。
你们胜气不
他们应该没听着吧？
他听着了
都听着了
他们说那有什么办法。
我们也反抗不了
我说大哥你就上台讲。
你反击
我说我有能力
我来替你们说话
他说好 谢谢兄弟。
你肯定有大伙子
你还说你是臭吐血演员。
有
因为有点也认识你。
因为有那个网约社司机后边那个。
车座后边那个大屏。
对对对
爱琪她买那个选择渠道了。
就放里面
这两个年
你少放
对对对
大屏
不开玩笑呢？
对不开玩笑
有不开玩笑
真的有
这么牛啊？
没有伤火
但有不开玩笑
上海地区
脱客
直接是不开玩笑
对对对
太牛了
我是
我跟网约社司机
我是特别有持感的跟他们聊天。
而且我特别容易愧疚。
比如说我上次去那个济南演出。
我们那个酒店
离那个济南火车站就有两公里。
遇到这种情况
我就不敢在站里面打车。
因为我知道他们排了很久的队。
就是你一打车他们就会生气。
他们要么就骂你
有的人会直接骂你。
要么就冷暴力你
对
营养你什么都有
对对对
你看他很不爽
他明明一举一动
他脾气很大在这
很生气什么什么的。
我都受不了
所以上次我去济南演出。
我就跟我一块的人。
我说咱俩就走出去。
我们就走了一公里。
济南站吗？
对
济南站有三轮
太Local了
我不知道
我当时我就拉
我很心虚
我就走了一公里
走到一个
因为一般火车站附近他也不让打。
就不让往车中央上。
他有一个进停区
我们就老老实实走了一公里。
然后打了一辆车
我们就怕那个司机。
我们一上断断的车司机。
司机就说哎呀？
还是你们好
刚刚在站里面接一单。
也是你们这个酒店。
然后开始跟我们骂他。
就把那个
但是那肯定不是骂我们。
就那种抱怨吗？
他们确实挺不容易的。
因为他们动不动
他们动不动在那个车站。
排三四个小时
济南站特别堵
你排三四个小时
你接个单十块钱
那确实是我让人很愤怒的。
在北京以前是首都局长去旺京。
就IBC
他们有一个好像说。
有一些机制
他们有个机制是
如果你接的这个单。
很近
几公里以内的话
免排队
下次来就能免排队。
那那个也得排队
只不过就比这个
是
还是麻烦
现在确实都不容易。
哎 问题
是我每次在那个红桥打车。
也是动辄就等半个小时一伤。
车也进不来
我也打不着
你坐一站地铁
除归在哪就快了
你太聪明了
我经常这么干
行
你这是阴阳外企还是正常沟通。
我正常沟通啊？
因为我确实没想到这一招。
大只爱就是
你现在听别人夸
你会怎么解读
你觉得是真心夸你。
我有哀夸羞耻
我认为我就是啥不是。
没有
你很真诚
你这句话得到了刘仁诚的肯定。
没有 我就不是这个意思啊？
我啥不是行
对对对对
那你会瞧不起成就不如你的人吗？
不会啊？
你就只否定自己啊？
我也不是否定自己。
我坚信一个观点
人跟人都差不多
大家都挺垃圾的
大致整体啊？
我说人跟人都差
要不然你看
要不然就沟通不了了。
如果你层次特别特别高的话。
对吧？
你怎么还能跟相互理解了。
不可能
其实人其实都差不多。
就你做成了吧？
你也没什么值得好教的。
完了
别人不行吧？
我老感觉可能就是他运气单纯不好。
我是这么感觉的
但脱口秀同行确实有的。
你想
有的就是走到那啊？
运气已经很好了都是。
我们录完咱们吃个饭吧？
哈哈哈哈
赶紧结束吧？
哎 我觉得这
谢谢大家拜拜
哎 我觉得这个点真的很重要。
就是沟通场域很重要。
比如说路波克尔这个场域。
肯定就不适合去聊些事。
嗯
但是比如说一些聚餐或者什么？
就很适合聊些事
把握
对是
说到那个
我觉得就是有一些服务业的。
就是大家这个沟通。
有没有一些比较有意思的事。
比如说那个通静老师离发的这种。
包括服务员
包括一些其他的
最近我开始找那种贵的剪头发的了。
我发你对贵的定义。
我们先定义这个
我听说多钱算贵
五千块钱以上
哦
不是马俊你大盆付钱。
干嘛呀？
就是开始定义贵了。
两百多呢？
那不便宜了
那挺贵的挺贵的挺贵的。
我以前人生没超没减过五十块钱。
五十块钱
两百多
咱你现在减一次
三十五
沈清你三十五十
就这些
我剪头一百块钱左右。
你想想我剪过最贵的是五百块钱。
我发现视频没有什么太大。
差别
而且五百块钱只剪一个流行。
离谱播
然后我发现根本没有什么差别。
我就再也不剪那么贵的了。
所以他们这行跟咱们这行也差不多。
这要价也天生一叫地生一叫。
主要看他们敢要吗？
因为我之前跟展也一样。
就我我只敢在长洲那个一直给我剪的人。
那那剪
然后就是三十五嘛？
但我就最近感觉如果。
因为太不方便了
比如他上海天日我想剪。
我就
但我在上海之前剪头都很不愉快。
就是不管花几十都没有用。
我前两天我家附近有那种。
bubber shop。
我咬牙进去了
bubbers
bubbers吧是bubbers。
到老王家来的
bubbershop。
b-a-r-b-e-r shop。
大家知道
他不知道
知道知道
bubbers
男士理发店啊？
对对对我觉得他真的。
反正他是真的听懂我的需求。
哎呦
一般这个怎么沟通你的需求。
没有就是我上次我想。
就是想剪一个发年他给我剪出来了。
我就是这是我
除了我从小剪那个人。
以外
最满意的一次
哎呦
所以我就觉得以后可以去他那剪。
那你
坐下之后有怎么跟他说吗？
你沟通话述大概是。
我们就是
表达自己需求吗？
嗯哼
你什么需求
你不就上面剪短两边剃了吗？
我当时的需求是
我说我想留着这个狼尾。
这
这个
屁股头笑什么笑
什么笑
哎呦
我怎么是屁股头啊？
没有逻辑啊？
我想骂我想不出来。
石老师他对你很不尊敬。
没有没有
我就想留着狼尾
然后刘海能给我弄短一点。
那别太短
但是能让整体看起来很舒服一点。
我最后剪刷我觉得挺好的。
现在已经长长了
就是后边留着
然后前面稍微剪短一点。
但是看起来比较舒服。
对
但就是因为你留着后面的情况下。
前面那个刘海很难把控。
对
很容易可能没剪
很容易剪成锅盖头。
这个其实挺考验
底发射的水
这不是锅盖头吗？
现在是因为长出来了。
长了有一个月了
我刚想说这个
就是你们有没有那种。
就是理发师
理发师比较常见啊？
女生的话可能还多一个没假这方面的。
他没给你剪出你想要的发型。
然后他先退卸责任。
怎么说
就先说你这脸型跟人家也不一样。
哈哈哈哈
你是哪个谁的脸型。
就跟人剪的
可能阿诚你又拿别人照片去。
啊我我我我说心虚了。
那会还真有
你拿着谁的
哎呀？
你想有狼尾的
有狼尾的那个爱的。
我收一下绝对想不到。
无存拓债有
那我知道了
不能提了
我能提你们
我让你们猜五个
才六个本你们肯定猜不到。
什么什么存拓债
不是
我好好就那我收一下。
中国的还是国外的中国的。
不是五百五百
阿诚拿着五百的粥。
就
收一下等会啊？
我看啊？
你们猜死也猜不到。
不是
再去问不是
王一伯王一伯不是。
刘雨凝不是
不是
猜死你们也猜不到于是。
你不会拿着弹火墙子照片去的吧？
猜死都猜不到
猜死你们都猜不到。
我拿的是
张鑫潮的
张鑫潮
他传
传统的理发师
没有没有
你们去搜他上个月草莓音乐节。
和回春的回春的
一块唱鲜花
他那就是狼尾
我觉得那个挺好看的。
我是拿着那个去的。
我怎么猜死也猜不到。
你这脸的回张鑫脸。
真
你看去这种情况下。
他还能让我满意
是不是他的水平很高。
那其实
那其实也是
其实也是他弄得好看。
其实我回家之后
我还挺美
我跟女朋友说
看我觉得这发音真不错。
人家跪跪确实有道理。
我一到晚上一洗
我就再也没见过那个发型。
对
再也没有见过了
他跟你抓吧抓吧？
对对对
抓到那个睡发的感觉非常好。
会
我不会
张鑫潮我真没想到。
我真没想到阿诚真的会拿一个照片。
去跟人家沟通
就是简单这样
我这跟你问着就这一次。
为什么？
那我摔得雨色呢？
这么多年就这一次。
我可太懂你了
我还跟我女朋友说。
这个发型适合我吗？
哎呦
阿诚还是
阿诚还是搁那个抖音视频接的图。
他不是说先看他接的图。
对呀？
他不会给你捡个三角出来。
把他说接个图
真真真挺好的
是这个
我当时感觉挺好的。
我们到时候把这个发型。
放到那个摄动里面。
好
我们把那个张鑫潮。
原版的发型放到摄动里面。
展演你一般去剪头发。
跟人怎么沟通呢？
我说你就
对
我
我现在是拿
你不给人看照片
我现在是拿一个照片。
谁
经济人又给我发照片。
他说那个你大概需要需要。
什么什么造型的照片。
我就把那个照片给他。
我说你就剪完事
能做成这样
就行
你不用跟我做
其实就是两边剪短。
上面剪短
没了
你每次就录节目时候。
有人专门装发
对呀？
肯定有装发
你有造型团队
没有造型团队
那玩你花钱就顾了。
就每次会单独请
对
今天我其实是反对这个的。
有反对造型团队
浪费钱吗？
那不是
就不如把这钱给你。
对
他就是也不给我
他我说也就不反对了。
就是也不给你
但有时候
有时候有的俱乐部。
他就是有
但如果你不去的话。
浪费人家钱就一点。
最近就得晃
其实有
确实是
因为大家都化妆
但我现在也不化
因为我稍微自然一点。
我以为我自己习惯了。
这也不是
就自己习惯了
但有时候很兴趣
有一回我发现
有一次我发现
对
有一次我跟假号
我们俩
没有
我们关系很好
我说这个是挺好笑。
就是我们都是
同一天专场
而且都是在上海
那天三点多
在家里玩抖音
因为我晚上七点半专场。
所以我不知道急
在玩抖音
我刷到假号
同样是在做专场
他在后台化妆了
就是那个先点
我还在家里面躺转手机。
七点半演出
三点半开始装发
对
他化妆要跟公众聊天。
他会直播
我觉得我特别心虚。
就是我感觉这样
适合有点不太好
然后密码举报了
好
立马划走了
我觉得这个就是
个人选择
你说你看起来香香的。
你们装发的时候
不满意会好意思直接说吗？
对
我就一个要求
快
随便
你会比如说
他给你画
你不满意要改
我从来没不满意
从来没有改过
我也是
我从来没改过
我从来没有现场不满意过。
我不来
我从来一种别人给你画。
我觉得我无所不看调。
只有去年
就咱们喜丹依你记不记得。
喜丹依第一次化妆。
那是拍外面东西
没有录真秀
拍那个路透
给我画了个妆
农的要死
但是我自己
但我也不会看
我也看不懂
看大翻那个照片
都说我什么像人妖一样什么的。
那是主要出现在你花城山上了。
没有
就是他画眼影了
他画了重眼影
后来每次画这种的。
跟老师说老师淡一点。
我没什么要求
淡一点就行
希望大家把那个发到评论区。
人妖一样
其他的
比如说大家去吃饭。
或者去做什么？
马杀机之类的
就是会有一些沟通吗？
我自己平时有时候会去那个。
按摩什么的忙按摩。
上楼差点能给我按死。
就是大
就是太大了
那推荐给我
我喜欢就是大的
因为阿承我感觉就是。
他不到万不得已
他好像不太沟通
对我一般就是不按死。
我就不说话
真是按死了你
我就是不按到受不了。
我就不说话
就是忙着也说
今天来个雅夫让我按。
但我现在
现在会提前说了
比如说我一般不让按脖子。
我因为我主要是脖子太疼了。
就是我是这样
我可以接受很用力的按。
但我的皮特别容易疼。
因为他有时候是那种纠皮。
脖子就不应该使劲。
不要使他按脖子
而脖子跟头我一般都不让他按。
我就说你就按背什么的就行。
一般会提前说
背什么我觉得再疼也能忍。
我就不太说话
哎呀我天
你这按摩是放松的。
你干嘛找罪受我
我以前也不好意思。
就按的我觉得这个人应该不是。
那个我
就是他找不准我的那个血位什么的。
以前不好意思说就忍一个小时。
我后来就觉得
我发现我干嘛要忍这一个小时。
我就可能五分钟十分钟。
我就说那个您受罚可能不太合适。
能换个别人吗？
我现在就这样
哦你会换人
对
这个
不会不道德吧？
老师们
没有没有
挺好的
提出诉求嘛？
但如果你按了五分钟十分钟。
那换一个人他给你。
还是按原来那个时间。
还是跑去这五到十分钟。
重新计算呢？
一般情况下
会有个别的那个按摩店。
他会跑去那个十分钟。
比如说你十分钟已经占了。
这会不会给你按五十。
但是一般都会重新给你计算时间。
这个跟那个店的就是消费水平。
那个规定
就是那个大概的那个档次有关。
如果人家一个小时可能就是什么？
八十块钱九十块钱这种。
他可能就给你跑了。
我在想呢？
我要是按到五十分钟说不合适行吗？
那你就不是人
按到五十分钟
老师我刚才
忍了五十分钟没说。
好像有的国家政院是这样的。
就前十分钟你出来。
就可以退全票
但是你不能说看到出字幕了。
你出去退票那就不合适了。
我上次按的太疼了。
上次我那次是因为我觉得按的挺好的。
就是疼而已
好疼
不是
盲人按摩就是要疼一点吗？
我感觉
不是吗？
应该是
我们都是舒服一点呢？
不是 就是
盲人按摩跟那种spot是两个概念。
盲人按摩就是得
傻点
就是得上劲
但那感觉确实不一样。
恶玩感觉挺舒服的。
恶玩舒服
就普通的spot呢？
因为一个叫舒缓
比如说有的追求按针可以睡着。
那些是spot嘛？
盲人按摩它是有那种什么推拿。
包括中医的那种调养的感觉嘛？
它是在找你身体的一些什么损耗什么的。
所以会很疼嘛？
反正我上次反正按的我特别疼。
我就特别想
我说下次我来的时候。
我要拿个手机
记录我的表情
我想发个抖音什么的。
应该能挺有意思
你怎么记录
你在那个
那个洞下面吗？
洞下面放个手机
对 然后拍自己脸。
哎呦 我的天 多吓人。
用手机屏幕
这么大个脸在这
好像有这个形式
有有有有
我就是看了别人看。
可以的
挺有意思
香港当年还有那种综艺呢？
就把什么正义件
陈小春放在那儿
请一个中医过来给他们按钮。
一般按钮让他们唱歌。
对
就是唱那儿
就这样
这个是个
很早的综艺了
是个让咸鱼去
大家跟这种比如说服务业的。
这些朋友有什么？
沟通的一些点吗？
大家好 我是来自17群的。
然后我想给大家
分享一下自己的经历吧？
因为我记得在甲方工作过。
也在以方工作
然后也遇到过
就是类似于前面
沈清老师跟阿诚老师。
遇到的问题
可能就是你们希望。
沟通少一点
就比如说需求列清楚。
这种是非常好的
但是作为服务方来说。
我们也遇到过就是。
有被打电话要求说。
再把这个
全部从头到尾
再介绍一遍
也是有可能的
所以就是也会有遇到过说。
他们确实有需求说。
是不是电话沟通
更清晰一点之中
因为确实他们有的。
会有阅读障碍
他们就是不想看
虽然我们会列得
非常清晰
但是他们就是不想看。
对 有这种人
我有语音障碍
我打电话现在会很大。
所有人只要给我打电话。
我现在就会变得
非常非常大
只要看文字就行
我是那种
然后作为假方的话。
你会发现
当我们是被服务的。
一方的话
其实以方的态度
就会非常好
然后他们会把
需求列得非常清晰。
然后他们会可能
间隔一天
或者是间隔几个小时。
跟你去check一下这个流程。
然后或者是一些
random之类的。
但是你也不能催得太过。
然后或者是
假方就会嫌麻烦
但是你作为以方的话。
我们如果不去确认。
就会有可能出现
各位老师
可能是不是会忘掉。
或者是miss掉这个信息。
当然确实非常难做。
就是夹在当中那种过程。
所以你在不同的公司。
工作的话
确实是会有不同的。
包括可能我们
沟通方式上面
如果你不加波浪号。
或者不加ner
然后可能会有加一。
就跟你说
你这个沟通
是不是太死板了
一板一眼
就是不是很活泼
就是确实沟通起来。
会有点困难
因为作为以方的话。
是提供
说白一点
就是提供情绪价值。
我们就是跟着客户走。
就是客户既然花了这个钱。
他钱到位了
那肯定是
更加要享受情绪价值的那一方。
不对
情绪价值无价
不应该有你们提供。
他就应该是
合同里有什么？
你们提供什么？
不用鼓掌
支持的人也不多
都是假方的可能都是。
那我觉得就是钱没到位。
不是
你波浪号
能提供他们多少情绪价值。
我唱哪个波浪号
我跟你说
你真的是
也谢谢这位姐妹
她让我想起了
我最近在吃的一个饼。
那个假方
她说话就是很会
宝子
宝宝
然后那波浪号
那她说
假方跟你说这些
对 宝
这个围款就不结了。
假不想杀人
情绪价值拉吗？
那个不是假方
那个有可能是
没有价值
你凭什么呢？
假方没有这个样
可能
那有可能是
三方就是秉方
或者是其他
哦 它是中间商
因为当中也有中间商。
就有可能贾老师不清楚。
就是为什么你们会觉得。
我们过来问报价的时候。
没有主动报价
因为可能我们也不知道。
你的报价可能是
需要
可能如果有经济人的话。
像我们如果约KOC或KOL。
他们
我们会有具体的报价。
有个账单
对
但是不知道具体的话。
可能我们也是在等待。
你们这边的报价
去进行沟通
因为确实也是
没有那么透明
如果没有经济人
确实也是蛮困难的。
对
这个
这个倒无所谓
不解围款
那怎么回事呢？
就是最近新仔出了一个广告。
博士伦的那个广告。
可能就是
如果是新仔那个
那个叫什么？
少爷和我的围粉的话。
会知道这个广告
然后这个广告是怎么回事。
就是博士伦
就是想出一个广告。
然后找到那个中间商。
中间商肯定不会写。
然后找一个会写
sketch的这个人。
然后就活儿
就落到我头上了
然后怎么回事
当时就说了
说你要是非得往这儿蹭。
就是你非得蹭这个少爷和我。
你可能会
人家会不开心
对吧？
就是那个粉丝会不开心。
因为你并不是找原班的演员。
你只找了新仔
跟另外一个人搭配。
然后你又直接蹭这个。
原著IP
你肯定会
可能
我说这个可能是比较大。
人家非要蹭
少爷和他
对
少爷和AI管家
少爷和他的朋友
这样
然后人家很很蹭
就是下
就是说
我说你再确实一点。
就是很很蹭
必须蹭
然后给他蹭完写完了。
最后就说
最后解款的时候
其实我们这个
已经相当于重写了。
这个
所以没用你们的原稿件。
所以我们这个围款就不结了。
然后我就说
那我们就看成片吧？
我当时就是傻就傻在这。
我说
因为我怕
他如果
我不加这个条例的话。
他就按原来的那个方式结的话。
那我就纯吃亏嘛？
所以我就说
那既然你说你没用。
这个原来的稿件
那我们就看成品
看有多少重合度
那重合度
低于40%以下
那围款不结就不结了。
因为就是代表你
确实可能大部分重写了。
但如果重合度高于40%。
那我们还是要追讨围款的。
对方很痛快
行可以立刻答应
后来我才知道
就不应该定这个具体的。
就按40%
对不应该按
不应该定具体的这个百分比。
因为这个很难界定。
因为最后发现成品是怎么样的。
成品是人家用了耿盖。
用了所有那个game点。
game点
大家明白什么意思。
就是那个
都知道太专业了你们。
用了耿盖用了game点。
然后把台词卡大量的删检。
所以如果真走官司的话。
那就是重合率不到40%。
但是我们就是被洗稿了。
然后对方不结围款了。
然后我们就哎呦我的天呐。
这个我咨询我本来想说。
我就出这口气
我不管就是哪怕
这个围款的钱
我都打官司了
我也跟你们硬杠到底。
结果律师就是纷纷都不建议。
所以我咨询的俩律师都说。
他们都说算了
说赢面没有很大
说可能五五开甚至四六开。
挺大了
这有大
我们是四老师
我知道啊？
那就值得一打了
五五谁五能不能打的。
肯定是你们四
四挺大了
真的吗？
对呀？
可是他们都不介意。
律师都说这个
他说他这个吃法官。
看法官就看法官
愿不愿意听进去
你们的这个所谓的。
行业规则
你看你还输了
咱就即使输了
是不也让他难受一下。
我更难受哎
因为我要付律师费啊？
我不仅没追回为款。
我还要付律师费
我还搭时间经历
但也行吧？
那你给我出资
不是出不出资的问题。
但是现在他
什么代价都没付
他他
好歹你要是打了
还让他出个停
让他知道就是
原来你也不是那么好欺负的。
哦是是
那以后就没活了
也我不差你
我现在叫曝光那公司。
也不是说不定
您发一份律师函过去。
对方也会付为款的。
可能没有全款
但也多多少
可能会补给您一点。
哦你是建议我发
一个律师函过去
对
律师函便宜
哦是吗？
律师函都把
都包就能省
哦
好那发律师函
就上淘宝买
上淘宝买
有律所就接这个单。
发律师函
哎呦
信豪你看我今天
出这事了
用淘宝选购
立刻
行
你是收钱了是不是。
不是这期
不是美团拼好饭
美团配色
哦我刚刚投诉的
可不是博士轮
是那个中间商
哦对因为这个博士轮。
也相当于
博士轮属于是受害者吧？
也属于中间商
两头坑
叫敌村什么什么公司。
我可不怕你干
我们支持你
我们给你录ID
哎我觉得如果出庭的话。
应该让宅去
不行
他去干嘛闹事啊？
他会被法官
不断的给制止
法官就不吃这一套。
我跟你说
是
好谢谢
谢谢这位朋友
还有哪位
来这位朋友
那个大家好
我是二群急速冷冻侠。
就是我
我刚才听到那个
工作上
想讲的发言
我想起来
今天有一个新鲜出炉的。
沟通问题
就是我们现在
正在谋划
做一个项目
然后大概有几百万。
然后我是
总的负责人
然后呢？
是要投我们吗？
就是
好了
不是
看一下
好
然后我现在
继续往下说
主要是
业务领域
不是很对口
然后呢？
就是联系了一家
供应商
然后我
是我的家二的领导。
拉了他们对应的
一个负责人
然后拉了一个群
然后把我
拉进去了之后
本身是跟他们
有电话沟通一下
当时呢？
也是
对方
然后也大概
讲了一下需求
那过了一个周末呢？
他们就想
找他们的一个
负责人来跟我对接。
然后我就看到
群里
他们的那个负责人。
发了一个截图
是我的头像和名字。
发到群里了
然后写了一句
这个是干活的
就是发错了吗？
对
他是想发给他们
他的下面的
一个对接人
负责人
然后发到群里了
被我看到了
我就一秒钟
就截了图
然后
他果然就撤回了
就他就
本来要跟自己人说。
这是干活的
这是领导
就是要去分开这个人。
一秒就截了图
对 我看见
我就知道他一定是发错。
因为我看
就是我的名字
然后这个是干活的。
就在那个群里边
你这个截图
留着有什么用呢？
那发给同社
然后我说
这就是上班的乐趣。
开心
就是小发雷霆
然后
对
但是人家过来
家伙的时候
我还是说
你好
对
还得继续沟通
是
对
但是我觉得
干活的责任
冒犯你了
是吧？
你确实有
就是我会觉得
他表面上
给你打电话的时候。
还是很客气
然后背后说
这干活的
那他发什么文字
你可以接受
他行吧？
这个人负责直情
这位是干活的老师。
对
就是至少说
这个是
这个是项目经历
你跟他对截
也可以吧？
对吧？
他就说
这个是干活的
对
然后当时他们人来家。
我就特别想回他一句。
哎呦
你问领导吧？
我一个干活的
能做什么主
就是很想回一句
好
谢谢
还行
确实这种
也有
所以群民
一定要管理好
一定不能认错
有
很重要
说发错
你那抖音的视频
我对你
他不一转发
对
一排一排投降吗？
有的时候你不后怕吗？
点错一个
那就废了
要给你
兄弟发的视频
你要点哪个女生
那可完了
那可
你懂了啥
你懂了
有那个就是
世界没啥的
对
怕把人家那个
减房破坏了
我以前还真发错过。
我还真发错过
但我都发错样视频。
所以对方也觉得
莫名其妙
我都以前是错样视频。
就不知道在干什么？
我觉得确实这种
比如合作方
包括老板和员工
包括父母和孩子
这种大家沟通
确实比较有难度
很多时候
我感觉还是合作方。
难度大吗？
你碰到我那种
会借为款的吗？
你会怎么说呢？
应该碰到我吧？
干了这么多年
应该碰到我
刚开始创业的时候。
真碰到我一次
宝子
我们这个围款就不结了。
因为你没有做到
什么？
都没有
你没收到我这种
他就直接没有下完。
一个说法都不给
然后你就
更惨
你就默默的
我连发票都开
你怎么填补
你虚开的那份发票。
那他不用就作废了。
自动作废了
那时候没收
你发票自动作废了。
我连发票都开了
就为了逼他借围款。
因为合同都签了
发票也开了
就是不借围款
那就没折
还是很大的公司
是你那点委屈算啥。
没事
对
我爸也会问我说
你现在全国到处演出。
会不会有结不下来钱。
我说一年演50场。
得有个一两场
我爸说算了算
他说差不多是这个比例。
他们经常
比如说在以前干工厂的。
给人家加工零件
基本上也是这个比例。
一百个活有两番个。
回不来钱差不多也就这样。
包括很多开超市的。
你被偷
或者被人家故意的破坏。
把东西给你捏碎了。
你就不能卖了
这个钱在你开超市那一天。
你就应该寄他进去。
他就没办法
你不可避免的
要碰到这种事情
所以这是一个
我们必须经历的
不是说靠什么样的。
沟通技巧能避免的。
对
没什么？
我说你所有技巧
不能现在我也发了。
你主要是说
你说蒋方
你好钱是不是
捷一下
这是石老师聊的事情。
扎牌已经开好了
到这个阶段
就不是沟通技巧可以解决了。
除非就是发力入境了。
是
其实有时候确实
想开了就好了
我自己还好
其实我演出
编剧好有过
但我演出还没收过。
就没有我钱不捷得清。
但有时候我特别替我爸。
因为
就是
做生意
装修
类似于工程
围块钱很难的
而且
尤其是一些
经常合作的包工头。
他的活你本来
你得打折
就本来
因为他你这样合作。
本来这100块钱就是90块钱。
结账的时候
又打一个折
本来利润就薄
我老是觉得
给他们干
感觉跟不赚钱一样。
而且你问他要钱
你还得带烟什么的。
对
很麻烦
我觉得挺生气的
这种比如说
除了这种公司之外。
比如朋友之间
如果要
催一些钱
或者什么之类
怎么沟通的
朋友催钱
催什么钱
很难催吧？
万一借了钱
他不还
我说实话
现在很多朋友
过得太难了
就我们这个行业
卡卡吗？
卡卡过挺好
这变据活不少
他其实正常还可以。
他一他能力还算
他机遇什么的
也都算不错
其实现在最难的是那些。
就是有些地方的
演员
因为现在演出真的很少。
基本就没有收入了。
我今年
去年过年
我借给朋友
一个朋友借了一点钱。
然后
今年有一次
在行之后
是演员是吗？
对 演员
然后跟他吃饭
其实我本来
也没想聊这个钱的话题。
他跟他吃饭
吃了事
我就赶快把蛋给买了。
因为我就觉得
太惨了
都不好意思提钱的时候。
最后也没提
因为我们吃饭
不是关于这个钱的。
吃饭时候就是说
借个面
那他提AA了吗？
他就说
哎 怎么把它买了。
他是想买
是我有点不好意思。
现在感觉
但我现在只会借
关系特别好的人
如果关系
不是特别好的
不会借
那关系特别好的话。
我就不吹了
家人之间
或者是
比如说
男女朋友亲密关系。
这种
家人
本来回头
我想说
自己录播课的时候。
说来着
也不知道精不精彩。
我找到一个
很好的
跟那个家人
沟通的这个技巧
前提是
就是
有点像这个
你从来没有
获得家人真正的认可。
然后这个是
一直是你心里的考。
你希望他们真正
认可你
一次的这种情况下。
我发现你主动要
他们会给的
你就说
妈 我牛不牛逼
然后我妈会说
牛
你牛
然后
我发现
原来认可没那么常要。
我就经常要
你这么问谁
谁敢说别的
那至少你那个
卡过了呀？
真的是
万明明十年前
就找我的技巧
谁
这么简单
万明明
万明明十年前
找我的技巧
你要我
要
这样吗？
怕我
对
对 我最近
我最近才发现
你会破你妈
我觉得你现在问
在场每个人
对呀 你这么问
谁不光你
你先问观众
你
但不一样
就前提是
因为很多人会有那个。
对 很多人会有那个心结。
觉得没有被爸爸妈妈。
真实地夸过一次
然后就觉得
你有铺垫吗？
你有前提吗？
就是
你就硬问
就是我牛不牛逼
还是说
你看我做了这些事。
我牛不牛逼
我忘了
我只记得我恶害的时候。
我发现
这样这么快就认可了。
好容易
然后就常常会要
但我会这样
我会冷不丁
再来点躺什么你知道吗？
蒸那个
在什么场合
蒸桑拿
再来点躺着呢？
啥话没有 冷不丁。
我问他
我说妈
你觉不觉得我是个奇迹。
然后我妈不说话
我们不说话说
听没听着我你
我问你话呢？
硬要是沟通
后来我妈说
你本来就是个奇迹。
就很治愈
我冒没问一句
你认为这是真诚的夸杂的。
是啊？
你一定是真诚的
这一定是真诚的夸杂。
你本来就是个奇迹。
我就说给你听的宅宝宝。
你就是缺这个
你需要跟你家长一次。
这种很激进的沟通。
你先问审情
不
我牛牛逼
我不问
我牛不牛逼我自己知道。
你该问
尤其你该问你爸
你该问你爸
你说爸
老子牛不牛逼
这家里谁是老的
我爸滚出去
真的吗？
你试一下
真不一样
试一下真滚出来了。
你多厉害
你也不能跟家长那么说话。
老子
还老子
老子开玩笑
我也没跟我妈说老牛牛逼。
我就说
其实就是小孩
我真的觉得你这个还挺酷的。
我从来没有跟家人这么沟通过。
是可以找那个语气。
软一点
你稍微软一点
你学一下大概是怎么样。
我学一下
你说真实场景吗？
对
真实场景
前面忘了聊什么了。
我说妈你不觉得
我其实挺厉害的吗？
然后妈妈说
然后妈妈就是错恶了。
错了一下就说
你很厉害你当然很厉害。
然后那一刻就是
其实非常治愈的
真的可以尝试一下。
行吗？
然后你心里就会觉得。
很多那些那个姐呀？
那个
哀哀哀哀哀哀哀哀哀哀哀哀哀哀。
能听见
本来疫苗数都还挺美的。
这一天想要冲测水。
一天就冲掉了
你脑子里都是傻呀？
因为一些奇怪的喜剧剂。
不好意思
就是那是冲掉了
就是那些坏都冲掉了。
所有你心里那些积攒的。
可能一些误会啊？
什么之类的
可能就是那一刻就化解了。
当时上中学的时候。
我有一次硬问我妈来这。
中学我觉得维持尚早。
你问啥
那时候妈妈的愧疚感。
可能还没有萌芽
我问我妈
我说我是不是长得还挺帅的。
我先支持你妈妈
那你还原一下
你当时怎么问的
一边摸溜好
一边问的
就是我当时我就大概。
就家里有一面那个落地的那个镜子。
然后我就在那
就很难用骚手弄姿。
那个词来形容
反正大概就是说
我觉得自己还
当时
中学那种小男生
应该都觉得自己还挺帅的。
都觉得自己还挺帅的。
但不会问自己妈呀？
应该自己照镜着就行了。
你当时怎么问的
妈
大概这种
大概也不露不露
这种流汗之类的
咋回的呢？
然后我妈很认真说。
还是你爸年轻的时候比较帅。
妈我就这个回答也还好吧？
没有特别
特别伤人杀的
他没有
他没有想伤我了
对
他没有觉得受伤
我觉得我女儿
现在我觉得小朋友。
他们
他们挺会沟通的
我女儿现在特会沟通。
我女儿
今天我接她放学
然后送她回去
她在路上
我们先走了几步
她说爸爸我想去便利店。
买一个吃的
我说
要不算了
然后她
立马就说
爸爸我给你两个选择。
你现在去便利店给我买吃的。
或者让我玩你的手机。
这咋的呢？
你说都不行
就回家了
他也在想
对
要不爸爸就有第三个选择。
我也在想
即便是我
我都会说
宝贝我也给你两个选择。
要么现在挨打
要么咱们就乖乖回去。
然后我又打了个哈哈。
然后她来说
那爸爸我给你三个选择。
要么现在玩手机
要么现在去便利店。
买东西
要么回家看电视
她一定
不断给我加
不同的选择
这就是
算了
这就是什么？
没事你
你是不是想说
这句是灌的
你是不是想说这句。
你去当贾的新闻发言人。
是不是
别说
越说越离不开了
别说了
但我就是也感觉
现在小孩越来越难沟通了。
可能也不是现在吧？
现在这个时代
因为小朋友
他们接触信息很快。
没那么好糊弄
加上
我觉得还是有些
成年人跟他们小孩工作。
还是有一些借钱在。
我发现自从我职责。
进入青春期之后
就沟通不了了
你侄子
刘仲刚的孩子吗？
对
我亲兄弟
亲侄子
会比我亲一些
但是
比如小时候
比如我以前
每次我回长州
我就遇到
比如他来遇到他
我都会跟他说
你有什么想吃的吗？
你有什么想玩的吗？
我去给你买什么的。
他现在都不会跟我说。
他就说没有
但肯定不是没有
他只是不想跟你说。
为什么不想跟你说。
啥意思
人家有自我了
他有自我
他怕你了
他不想
他就不想要你的东西了。
但是你其实就是
只是想
是吗？
你说
叔叔给你买iPad。
要不要
我真的给他
我真的是这样子的。
他的游戏机又跟他买的。
那不要了吗？
要了
但是他爸妈现在
不让我给他买新的了。
还有你的界限在
他叛逆的方式
就是不跟你索取了。
不是
不跟你沟通
不是说不跟你索取。
就是不跟你聊
就是你了解不了他了。
这是
还是青春期了吗？
对
我就觉得挺难受的。
正常
是
谁青春期不爱当家豪。
小孩还是要教育的。
不是说
那个不打呀？
是
我就看
那个小孩
给我印象特别深刻。
我当时都想教育教育他们。
有一个小孩
是我六狗的时候碰到。
他拿一个树枝
一直在敲地
因为他一直在敲地。
所以我没有
没有反应过来
什么意思
然后等我
六狗走过的时候
那个iPad是刚走过去。
然后他
因为他一直在敲地。
他就
才说打死这只狗
如果他在我
经过那一瞬间
说了这句话的话
我当时一定
跟他妈妈说
你孩子怎么这样
但是你说
但是
我不知道是小男孩。
心里的暴力
还是
我不知道是一个小男孩。
这样还是说
因为还遇到过一个小男孩。
我在咖啡厅
然后当时在咖啡厅。
用电脑什么的
那个包就放在
旁边座位上
他上来就把
他说
这谁的包
把我包撇了
就直接撇了
然后我当时
我也很震惊
然后我就说
你不能扔别人的包。
然后他后面
还抓那个狗
因为那个店里
本身也有狗
他抓那个狗
然后放到沙发上
然后就拿一个小东西。
敲他的背
然后我说你不能打狗。
然后可能因为
我制止了两次
这个小孩的行为
所以旁边有一个店家说。
这是老板娘的儿子。
然后我
然后我当时想说
谁的儿子不能这样。
但是我觉得
没有必要
我就说好
就没那个
那小老师我问你
面对这种小男孩
你说得教育
得怎么教育
就告他不能这样啊？
告他不能这样
你以为没人告过他吗？
你以为你是
第一个告他不能这样的吗？
他肯定是告完之后。
他还这样的
我觉得是不是
有没有可能是那个家长。
没有很严厉的
对没有很严厉
那你是那个家长
该怎么让他
学会这个道理呢？
这是我的孩子
假如你还是
就是打
你自己说一百遍了。
他就拿锅
敲去小狗后背
怎么办
那我可能会
咨询心理医生
他是不是有什么问题。
他是不是反社会
他是不是
孩子的基因
是不是有什么问题。
是不是基因突变了。
或者是孩子会不会。
平时压抑了
很多负面情绪
是我给他什么压力了。
我可能会咨询一下专家。
如果真的是
摆说不听的话
宅家军
宅家军没有做到
他想要的答案
你希望我杀了他
他希望一顿毒打
沈清当然知道
宅家军想要什么答案。
但是那不是
正确答案
他们就是把问题
弄得太复杂
对
我感觉
你是不是那个
计划论的
这个披露我
你怎么计划到现在。
怎么文明进步
这么多年
你还在约使时代
你是不是
找对象那种
扛洞里那种笑容
怎么会这么原始呢？
一点儿
肌肤一点儿文明如恼笑。
你要千万别说话
我们还是应该聊台干。
是
对
但现在小孩就这样。
我也感觉到
我今天过年
因为我没事干嘛？
我就老去
我们网吧打游戏
我发现小孩
现在小孩
在网吧特别吵
而且嘴上特别脏
所以说以前小孩也脏。
但他们不会在公共场合。
这么大声的喊
整个网吧都是那种。
闲年轻人在那儿
骂一些脏话
然后一个比一个大声。
没有任何有
这种公共场合的概念。
甚至网吧很吵
你也不应该那样吼。
而且都是很难听
很难听的话
大家还是
太文明了
我是实情实义的
我是经过深思熟虑之后。
才认为暴力是必要的。
你知道吗？
不是说
我天然就喜欢暴力。
只是我经过左右脑祸。
深思熟虑的逐字分析。
我认为就应该倒
就得倒
或者说一病的干预。
恐惧本来就是
教育的一环
对
就是用某种方式来。
告诉他们这个是不对的。
对
饿两顿
打狗吗饿两顿
要狗吃饭他看着
不就好了吗？
一打狗就
就不能跟狗吃饭就看着。
但这样也不太好
咋的
这样会让他恨上狗。
他会容易对狗子一事。
你要再说
他如果本质坏
他怎么的都恨一个点啥。
那狗没惹
他打狗怎么回事
对吧？
上海还是太文明了。
太文明了
你不是就生活在杭州吗？
杭州跟上海现在
差距都越来越大
就是人对这个
透露观众
这人是真事的
我还准备后边
有机会要讲这个事。
这个断子真的
天哪
杭州透露环境
跟上海透露环境
就跟水洋跟上海透露环境。
没有区别
差不多
真的
我负责那个各位说。
我就有个断子
可以送给各位
你看
真实 真实情况
军科你去过
一直卖奖
奖开往卖吗？
前排观众就是
主持人一般看着
互动您是做什么？
您是做什么的
上海还是都是
我是干什么？
我是干什么的
杭州现在就是说
前排你做什么？
你说什么的
两个法师一个猎人。
现在
真事的
就全世界的观众
分层已经巨严重了。
你想象不到的
连个辅助都没有了。
真事的
我透露环境
现在在我看来
真特别隔离
特别
特别隔离
我都不知道跟谁
输这个苦头
今天算来着了
这不是什么？
不想给各位添堵
我们问问大家
就是跟比如说
家人
不管是父母
还是下一辈有什么？
很难沟通的一些点。
时刻
我是想说一下
就是比较难沟通的瞬间。
但是应该在上海
会比较引起共鸣
就是
被爸妈催婚的时间。
催婚
对
就是怎么说
都是说不通的
其实昨天
我本来有
参加这个播客录制的。
因为我投稿了
那个专业人士
我想说一下
我们
我是农村人
我们老家就是有很。
我感觉是一个固定的习惯。
就是女性
一旦超过45岁
就会自动的话
生成了美婆
自动的就开始给大家。
介绍一些对象
后来
大家聊得多了
我就会
转一话题
问那家个姐姐
有没有找到
我听下来
我该去他们那村
谢谢
因为我不拍视别人。
给我相亲
我还气
没人给我介绍呢？
那一般
比如给你介绍对象。
是怎么沟通的跟你。
就说有这么一个人。
候选对象
好啊？
比如
我觉得相亲
也是很重要沟通
比如说见了之后
你一般沟通点啥
这我不是在这讲过吗？
我说我相亲
两个挺不错
男生都没看上我
对
他喜欢的看不上他。
看得上他
他不喜欢
没有人看得上我
我怕还把你嫁一般呢？
两个都没看上我
那具体聊什么细节。
我老师徒开点什么玩笑。
比如说
但其实第一次相亲。
不太适合开玩笑
适合缅舔
适合安静优雅
适合一些大家就是。
但你现在很难了吧？
我感觉
你装优雅
还送你视频
你一个呢？
读个紙条骂人
那么全看见了吗？
我跟你说
就是这样的
因为第二个
第二个那个人就是。
非要看我
听我播客
要老那个什么？
老在问你什么播客。
你什么播客
因为旁边介绍人就说。
他录播客很厉害什么什么的。
他非要搜我
然后就在这
别搜别搜别搜
因为我怕他一下
就看到太真实的我。
然后就觉得那啥
有负担吗？
我一直在别搜别搜。
然后因为我强烈的。
让他别搜
他可能
不想搜了
不是
他就觉得我对他
是一点没意思
因为他最后跟那介绍人说。
感觉这个人
对我们也没什么意思。
那算了吧？
对
因为他其实那个话。
已经递得很那个
他就说什么？
就是反正就是说
说一些就是很想看看。
就是很想看看
真实的你
你还没有说真实的你。
反正就是想
他说他不听播客
但如果你的播客的话。
我很愿意听一听
了解一下你
然后我还在那说
不行不能搜
不能搜
我觉得你下次可以。
反其道而行
什么反其道而
就是搜
搜
我知道了
见面之前先狂给他。
发我的视频卡段
接受得来
然后问见不见
你干脆就在
这期评论区
下边争计
给他发卡段
完了他给你回
小老师怎么能参加你。
见面报名那样的
我给他
过票链接甩过去
对
先买票
买完再行
对
这也算是一个收获了。
你们有没有觉得
那种简单的
一些沟通的时刻
比如说
比如说要提离职
或者分手
或者是这种
我觉得离职跟分手。
真的很像
是吗？
你是最近有
经历那个吗？
还是
我们不提最近
提提想当初
包括长工资
提长薪
我觉得也挺难的
你要跟老板提
长工资
长薪还行
就是离职的时候
我不知道你当年
从效果离开的时候。
有没有
这是逆林吗？
我不知道
不是 可以了
你做效果的是吧？
我怕真的伤到你
能不能说
你用个明确的事
你的表情是什么意思。
给我下一条
就是我
因为我当时
从效果离开的时候。
虽然我没有离过婚。
但是我有那种
非常强烈的
仿佛离婚的那种感觉。
你有吗？
我的意思就是离职。
从效果离开的时候。
就不说离婚
离婚太重了
就是分手的那种感觉。
对吧？
我觉得离职跟分手。
真的很像
尤其是从效果这种地方。
感情
一开始大家什么？
抽创公司
然后大家没什么人的时候。
对
然后一开始
谁也不计较回报
就一枪热泄
在一起
然后后面
其实真的分开的时候。
那个感情其实挺复杂的。
那你当然怎么提的。
我说
我忘了我怎么提的。
我写了个离职信
我记得
然后离职信
我自己写的很动情。
然后再去面谈
面谈的时候
是因为他说
那你这个一人约
就还保证
然后我说
那还是不要了吧？
因为我也要出去吃饭。
我也要有眼出什么的。
我说咱们还是都解了吧？
但是我也表达了
但这不是
不是一种话术
我是真心的
我真心的很不舍头。
但是我也真心的觉得。
得分开
对
因为那个
对于我来说
说专业点
就是我职业没有成长。
我在这公司待了四年。
我看不到我的成长变化。
我觉得我被框死在价值体系里了。
所以我说我得出去。
就是我那时候
表达了非常多的不舍都是真心的。
但我也确实得走
对
所以当时真的很像分手。
就是我还爱着你
但是咱们真的不合适。
就是那种感觉
你没有
有有有
当时我也提的时候也是这样。
难受难分
然后也被挽留了一下。
挽留很多次
对我没有那么多次。
你赢了
也没什么好攀比的。
有点像
包括你看后来
这个当时说的有点那啥了。
就是比如说
我从小过走的时候。
你看后边那些那个啥。
一些新人
因为也都是我招进效果的。
就在看他们
然后就有点觉得
咋的呢？
就感情比较复杂
是
马军提过离职
我提过
我后面好一点
我第一次提离职
是当时想从福州新东方回厦门。
然后一直不知道
因为那是第一份工作。
然后又年轻
不一直不知道
怎么跟校长谈这个事。
后来那个校长说
马军来
你说想走
我说是
我说你怎么看出来。
他说你离职两次
都写脑本上来
年轻
后来就说
那你也别离职了
我们就办一个内部动力。
这样的各种社保
转过去
还不用断什么的
非常好
我在职场上
基本上
还没遇到过什么坏人。
对
这个挺好的
我当时走的时候
其实也聊得比较直接。
我就说我确实觉得。
有一些自己的想法。
然后想離开
然后换一个
换一个环境什么之类的。
然后最后
反正也有一些拉扯。
但是也就这样了
就这样了
然后当时我记得跟叶老师。
最后还聊了一次
他说
之后
还可以投你
投了吗？
没有
这不就客气一下吗？
你还当真
你要了吗？
是不是也是一个关键呢？
像我一个审情似的。
你就跟他说
叶老师
我是不是该投
我牛不牛逼
我是不是该被投一下。
直接一个招股书
寄过去
后来也没有再谈这个事了。
但其实也还挺好
就当时也没有聊得特别的。
没有沟通得很不愉快。
是
你没离过职吗？
离过呀？
都不愉快
说呀？
没有啥说的
我就要走
那时候
每一工作
硬沟通
我扛得不沟通
那就军哥刚才说的大位。
他就是让我干这干那。
我说干不了
我一个人怎么干这老些活。
然后他说那就给你调港。
我调不了
我得讲透口秀
他说那你就十二月份完了。
你就走
我就走就走
我太好了
我每次我跟你讲
上班最开心的
就是要快走那一个月。
啥不干
那一月工资给你
在这一月
你就天天就是投减力。
完了抹鱼
早下来活就完事了。
相当于给有一个
带的赖找着工作的一个假期。
你只要放下你这个。
所谓的公司责任感。
你活得就很开心
我记得十二月份提离职。
后来十二月就是中学的时候。
领导来了看你
我上班
我就跟他玩看视频。
他不管你了
能够啥那场
你成流氓了你
哪有啥流氓的
就有底气那时候
那个同事那时候就问我。
说那报销什么？
你都不要
不怕都不给你
我说我跟你不一样。
我脱口秀这么多
真不差这两个
我就直接这么给我同事手。
所以警共贪好
对
如果你脱口秀
挣得不够多的话
就今天
我没有这种
就是什么？
像分手
这什么体面
完全没有
我上班时候就不爽。
我就就骂
比如说
就是哪个领导傻逼。
我就跟同事就骂
我说
他就是傻逼
跟同事骂
我以为你去领导
当面骂的
跟同事骂说这么牛逼。
跟同事
谁不跟同事骂
跟领导骂
就开会的时候
他就是
就有那领导
就说这些是我干的。
我就直接指着我领导。
我说这他们你干
这不我干的
我就直接这么说
这他们你干的
对
完了那大领导就说。
那个你小展你冷静你作业。
你对那个公司
那还是不错的
你确实干点活
但你不能这么说话。
那时候我就已经要走了。
就那个军哥说
那个什么姓朱那个。
我问他说话
我就直接问他
我说我天天去销山。
你干啥了
你个办公室一坐
完了你倒点就问我干啥了。
你咋一回不去呢？
我就这么问他
他自己一声不值
他就说
他就他原话对我
他说我要都去了
我要你干啥
我说我要都干了
我怎么样你干啥
我就这么跟他说
你是
你是不是没碰着过东北领导。
我哥工地怎么跟人打起来的。
东北领导
是
什么？
隶水领导
浙江
浙江隶水领导
他就骂东北人不行不行。
我就跟他打起来了。
对我确实仅供参考。
仅供参考
太仅供参考
就存讲理由反正
你得
这就讲理
我认为我非常讲道理。
如果你真做到了
谁能跟你那态度
你得有宅家宁的肌肉。
同事有宅家宁的副业收入。
才能这么跟自己的本职领导这么说。
他有宅安面想
缺一不可
我其实当年来说脱秀的时候。
我跟我家人沟通就挺难的。
他们都不愿意让我来。
这个太正常了
对
你为什么要跟你家人说。
你说就完了
你告诉他干啥
这行业很多人在干吗？
就来讲就完了
但是有意说一时
老师你当年也三十多岁了。
是
这也要征求家人的同意。
才能
也不是征求他们同意。
但是你不得跟家人沟通一下。
知会一下
通个气
这行业很多人都是不说。
都瞒着
对
你说了干什么？
你都瞒着
我就上节目
我爸妈才知道我讲脱秀的。
很多人都这样
对
就二十四年才知道我讲脱秀的。
之前呢？
完全不知道
就是在上班
他以为我在杭州给人补课。
还是第一份工作
就是我说语言行业。
跟人家同学一起干。
他以为我周末就去南京。
去他们苏州给人上门。
上当家劲
阿诚你当时也是没说。
我说了
因为我知道我家人的情况。
但是我不跟他们多说。
我说我去上班了
然后他们
然后他们大概知道我在干什么？
当然也不会细问
因为我家人他不会主脑。
所以我就在说
但是行业里很多
比如说像
包括像孙子彤也是。
他也上节目
他家里才知道的
对
很多人都是这样子的。
那我说说
很多人上节目
他一轮以后
他就希望家里人别看。
别看
这样他就继续
不知道他的说筒
对
要不然会更担忧他。
因为我们上一半
基本上就觉得
拓球不是什么正经行业。
现在也
我们这一半也是吧？
上一半
认为你什么都不是正经行业。
除非这个行业
能让他明显的指导。
你有一定成绩
对
要么他认为都不是正经行业。
是
这马俊应该深有体会。
嗨
这都是过去的事情。
对
因为我当时
我爸妈就觉得
他们特别想让我有一个。
稳定的工作
但是我一说脱口秀。
他们就觉得
就不够稳定
哪怕我后来
我一下子在新东方。
然后后来我自己出来创业。
也做了一个小的
英语培训机构
然后他们都觉得
这个也还行
就是常务副校长
那种感觉
他们能归到一个
这个title里边。
他们就觉得OK
那你脱口秀
可以归到哪个大类呢？
是不是也能归到
一个比较大的
就是好听的那个title里。
没有 自由市场职业。
对 算自由市场
马俊给归一下
小丑
差不多
第三行业
服务业
那就服务业 第三行业。
对
第三产业
那最后咋接受的
最后没什么？
他们就说
行不行
你干这个
我不太放心
但是反正
人也大了
我确实也30多岁了。
现在都40多岁了。
笑点在哪呢？
笑点在你
会算数真棒
人家好歹是硕士
所以也管不了了
对
而且毕竟离得很远。
我在上海
他们也管不了了
然后就接受了
所以是一种很无力的阻挠。
也没干啥
就是表达了一下质疑。
表达说
这干这个都不稳定。
都不好
没算什么？
对
所以大概也就是这样。
但我其实支持大家。
我觉得有时候跟父母。
没必要聊那么多
对
你何苦呢？
双方找男生
对
但如果
比如他们要买一些。
这种骗钱
理财产品什么之类。
他也不会告诉我
他买了我也不知道。
你也不会告诉我
对
每一个人都
主打一个不熟
每一个人都有自己的命运。
你不要老
不要介入别人的因果。
对
他买他就能买
你要
你要拦着他买
他就赖你
对不对
他买了被骗
他难受
对吧？
就这么点事
除非他张嘴求你了。
你帮他办啥
他会感激你
要不然他就
你要是强行
把自己说
我要对你好
主动去干啥
我感觉都没有必要。
这五十多岁人了
谁不明白这事
好
接不住了
接不住
只能期望大家
所有的亲子关系
都要宅佳宁
在他们家这么简单就好了。
互相不沟通啥事没有。
要真这么清楚就好了。
他也沟通
他爸妈老给他发微信。
然后你从来不理
我们都能看着
我理
我讲过
我再给你讲一个
不讲也行
我不是上一轮
就是给观众跪下了吗？
是吧 那视频
我就挺激动的
玩了我妈
就说什么？
那个儿子
在外边
一定要照顾好自己。
记住
父母永远是你坚强的后盾。
另外儿子
可别太水性
别在公共场合磕头了。
男儿膝下有黄金的儿子。
不要轻易去跪
跪天跪地
跪父母
别人都不配啊 儿子。
观众就是你的医师父母。
你能
你能咋的
我就护我妈一个
抱全拱手
完事了没
你跟他解释啥
你再跟他说
我那个妈
我不是怎么怎么贵。
他直接就回你
我知道
但是也别怎么怎么？
你都知道会发生啥了。
你要不想让他发生。
对彼此都好
你就说完事了没
我妈给我发啥
我要么这个
要么这个
完事了
要么抱全
要么OK是吧？
对
要么还有这个
就完事了就
挺好
好 吃醋
对
好 我们这样
我们掌声送给我们今天所有朋友。
好吧？
我下次聊沟通
还是不请大展
聊多好
但是我觉得今天还挺好的。
挺好的
聊了一些不沟通的艺术。
如果这期你要收的话。
应该怎么收
我要收
大家想沟通就沟通。
想不沟通就不沟通。
怎么得劲怎么来
多简单
不是
他其实我不爱说这种话。
因为我一直认为
这都是每一个人
本能就能做到的事。
大家都成年人了
我每次说这种话
我都老感觉是
幼稚圆老师跟孩子说的话。
是
对
我每次都感觉
说一个就是正确的废话。
真没意思
节目他妈得每个人。
都自己把这么数吧？
一张就
我们要勇敢
我都32了
怎么让你教我勇敢。
你自己想想
这都是5岁
5岁那小朋友
又然挺老师这么说的话。
大家有吃饭的时候。
告诉我这点讽刺谁呢？
但没办法
你们不好奇吗？
都是就那样
沈清 如果是你
节目你怎么收
如果我已经半小时之前。
我就收了
怎么打的
好
我们还吃饭去了这会。
八卦都挺一半
10分钟之前
就一直想说一句话。
一直忍着没说
我说有没有人跟老师。
过通一下该结束了。
那我们就录到这吧？
谢谢大家
谢谢
辛苦了
是我的事
感谢大家收听本期不开玩笑。
欢迎大家来不开玩笑。
听友群一起聊天
关注公众号
貓咪喜剧回复听友群。
小助手会把你拉进群聊。
更多精彩演出信息。
可以在公众号
貓咪喜剧查看
我们下期再见